Doom,
doom,
dum,
three,
two,
one.
Oh,
ladies and gentlemen,
we've got a sweet show today.
Cameron Hanes is in the building.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Cameron Hanes.
So what's up brother Scott?
Motherfucking eastwood is in the House
and if you can't see me it's because I'm
wearing this sweet underarmour cammo
shirt and I do tend to blend into the
background.
So if you get confused and go where it
was,
Joe's head just floating in the air like
that.
But if you,
if you could see it,
you'd be,
you'd noticed you look Jack Jack's
right.
Is tight form formed into an appealing a
tail on it.
It's a floating head.
So a cams in town were shooting both
today.
And I know he gave you a bowl yesterday.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He,
uh,
we,
we went down to riverside,
riverside our tree and to check out a
show me throw me a blow by blow.
So that was
cool.
You had an old,
had an old bow.
We'd,
we had an upgrade.
Didn't way.
What was the old bell?
It was an old Ross.
It was Ross probably from like,
yeah,
same company.
No,
I didn't,
I didn't even hurt.
Is Ross in archery company a big archery
company?
No.
Small.
Yeah,
it's small.
I don't know.
I'm not even sure if they still don't
make them anymore.
This was like a secondhand Bo.
I bought off somebody a years ago.
So is this something you wanted to do
for awhile and somehow or another you've
got to hold the cam?
Uh,
I don't remember how we got connected.
Did we instagram?
He likes to say I slid them a dad.
Desperate girl.
I think.
I mean I always put up hunting stuff
obviously and I think you commented
maybe or something.
So it wasn't like an unsolicited dom
like,
hey,
I'd like to get to know you a little
better,
but I think it was a little bit okay
too,
you know,
if you know,
it's all good.
I mean it's 2017.
Everybody's free to express themselves.
So if something like that built on.
And then we just started archery and are
talking to archery than hunting and you
know,
he,
he grew up in hunt his hunted and had
the bow and so he got done with this
movie stuff and was here and thought,
hey,
let's get together.
Also
the public land stuff to uh,
you know,
been noticing you guys both been talking
about that.
And so I was really interested in that.
So I started reading up about it and,
and I just said,
you know,
hey,
how can I help?
How can I get involved because this
means a lot to me.
I'm a native Californian and I grew up
going to yosemite,
you know,
going hunting and fishing,
uh,
using the public lands.
And so it was really important to me.
You know,
my dad was a state parks commissioner.
Uh,
most people don't know that.
So when was this?
This was,
this was gonna be before he was the
mayor?
No,
no,
no.
After this.
Really?
Yeah.
This was after.
So fairly recently then?
Yeah,
probably in the last,
I would say 15 years.
I know he,
he,
he did it for awhile and then got out.
Um,
but you know,
he was,
he was big and um,
in the,
uh,
do you remember the toll road going
through the
San Clemente?
No,
I'm not aware of that.
Yes.
So they,
they,
they were proposing a,
this was an arnold Schwarzenegger was a,
was an office and they were proposing a
toll road to go through San Clemente
which goes through a trestles,
which is a popular surf break and uh,
he was,
you know,
everyone,
got behind it,
um,
surfrider foundation because he didn't
want it because it was going to destroy
the wave and ultimately destroy the
national park there.
And so he was big on that kind of stuff.
And so I've always been,
you know,
sort of following in his footsteps and
hang on,
we gotta we gotta get in front of this
problem.
Did you dad's clint eastwood crazy.
Yeah.
That is so crazy.
What is it like having Clint Eastwood as
a dad?
What's Your Dad do?
My Dad is clinics would bitch would just
be like,
oh shit.
He just walk away confused like what
happened to me.
I just got hit with a rock and you look
like a weird,
like when I'm looking at you,
I see your dad like from the old outlaw
Josey Wales days.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
you know what's crazy is looking at
photos of him when he was 12 and I was
12 a,
you cannot tell the difference.
You put them in both in black and white.
You can't tell the difference.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a trip.
What was it like growing up with him as
a dad?
When did you realize like,
Holy Shit,
I think I realized I'm 31,
so I'd probably realized when I was
about eight,
I watched unforgiven.
Yeah,
he let you watch that when you were
eight.
That's my favorite movie ever.
That high plains drifter is right up
there too.
Wow.
I don't know.
It's,
it's hard to lock them down,
but the unforgiven is a dark movie man.
It's dark money.
William money killer of women and
children.
That's a dark movie,
man.
Y'All got to come in.
What he says in that,
when I learned that I'm just like
probably one of the most realistic
killers too,
like the way handled stuff and the way
everybody else was like falling apart.
You never saw that in those movies.
What was it about regret?
It was about a,
a life filled of,
uh,
of regret and filled the things that you
did wrong that you wish you could have
done better.
And um,
you know,
it was sort of a last one last ride to
be,
to do something better for his kids,
you know,
so that,
I think that was sort of interesting.
It was,
it was sort of a final culmination of
all his westerns.
It really was.
And almost like he updated the mall too
because like in the old movies,
like you'd have cowards,
you need to have heroes and stuff like
that.
But in the unforgiven he took it to a
totally different level.
Like psychologically,
you know,
like even the way he,
like the switch goes off when he starts
drinking and then he started just
fucking merch and everybody like the way
it was handled,
it seemed so realistic the way everybody
would fall apart and gunfights and the
way you get to watch it again now.
It's been awhile now.
I'm like,
that sounds awesome.
Fucking great.
That's fucking great movie.
I remember seeing it.
I remember the movie I want to see in
the movie theater and when the credits
roll at the end,
I
just want to do this powerful one.
Yeah,
it's intense movie man.
Fucking intense.
So when you're eight you figured it out
like that movie,
right?
It right around then.
Yeah,
I remember watching it and I'm not sure
if I watch it with him or shortly after
he had made it.
Um,
and just thinking,
you know,
that is the coolest thing and I want to
do that.
You know,
I wanna I want to be in movies.
I want to tell stories like that.
Wow.
So how many,
and you have brothers and sisters and so
how did all that work?
Uh,
yeah,
I've got,
I've got a few sisters and my dad was a
busy guy.
How many kids in the family?
Uh,
how many wives?
yeah,
let's just go with that.
There's a,
he's only had two wives,
but he had a few,
few girlfriends,
few babies.
Mamas.
Yeah.
So did you live with him?
I did,
I did.
Uh,
I would bounce back and forth.
I lived with my mom.
I live with my mom in California until I
was about a seven or eight.
And then I lived.
Then we,
did she move,
she packed up this kind of run the time
when they split,
was your mom and actress to.
No,
no,
no.
She was just a normal person.
Yeah,
flight attendant.
Uh,
she had two kids with my dad and uh,
we,
she packed up,
I think when they sort of split and she
moved to Hawaii,
she had lived there when she was a lot
younger and so she had always loved
Hawaii and so I had gone to Hawaii to
live,
uh,
probably from about eight to about 16.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then they ultimately moved back with
my dad for like the last couple of years
of high school.
And so yeah,
it was,
it was an interesting upbringing,
right?
I mean,
you know,
one hand,
I was with my dad for some time and when
I was in Hawaii,
a living there and you know,
if you know anything about Hawaii as,
as a white boy growing up,
uh,
you're,
you're the minority.
Yeah.
So it was,
it was a lot of,
um,
a lot of fist you just show up with a
Harley tee shirt on.
Rewarding.
I mean,
that's,
you know,
a lot of people don't realize that it's
pretty,
you know,
Hawaii's very from like a warrior
society still.
And,
and that's a great thing kind of because
it's still,
it's very primal.
Uh,
and it's also,
you know,
sort of,
it's one of those things where,
um,
there's not a lot of tolerance for
someone that you don't know or part of
your family.
Um,
and so,
you know,
for me it was,
it was,
it was tough.
It was,
it was.
Did they accept you eventually?
You know,
sports,
Sports,
sports really bridged that gap.
A football.
I played football and that was,
that really.
It was tough because the first year they
were like,
no,
they were like,
get the fuck outta here.
Suck.
Um,
yeah,
you know,
I was,
I was a kid then I was probably,
I don't know,
I can't remember 10 or so playing pee
wee football.
Right.
And then as,
as you know,
as I would,
you know,
prove myself that I was down for hard
work and uh,
you know,
down to throw hits that,
that sort of,
you know,
a bridged the gap and then ultimately
they were part of my team and then so we
would go to other schools and play other
schools and then I was still the,
the Halle boy to everybody else,
but they had my back now.
So that was cool to be a bizarre time
man,
to be a 10 year old and all of a sudden
be in that environment.
Sure,
sure.
That was,
um,
it was different.
It was A.
Yeah,
I didn't know any better,
so I'm going,
okay,
well this is what I got to deal with now
is the cards are got dealt,
so they're going to man up.
Yeah.
I have a bunch of buddies live in Hawaii
and you know,
they say that if you're respectful and
you're,
you know,
you're not a Douche bag like after
awhile you just fit right in and
everybody's cool with it.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's uh,
I grew up also as a surfer,
you know,
as grownups,
grownups surfing and so there's
definitely a pecking order and a respect
there that you have to learn or you're
going to learn the hard way.
Um,
and,
and that's,
I think that was a good thing,
you know,
ultimately because it kind of humbles
you and makes you,
makes you know your place,
which is good.
Did you start training Jujitsu there?
Uh,
I started,
uh,
you know,
actually I'm not.
One of my good buddies who passed away,
Paul Walker got me into a Jujitsu.
Um,
he got me about six years ago.
Six maybe,
maybe more now.
Yeah.
He was like a purple belt.
Right,
or a brown belt,
brown belt when he died.
Um,
and so yeah,
he,
he was,
I mean he was a diehard.
I mean he had a place in Hawaii actually
and he had uh,
he would,
he would go get matt and he would get
his place outfitted so he could practice
at home.
I don't know.
Um,
and he got me,
he got me involved and that's,
you know,
that's another thing that's great about
a over there.
It's like you really realize like
obviously,
you know,
a jets is like the ultimate humbling,
for people especially for I think for
men carry a lot of ego around or carry a
lot of,
you know,
I think as men we're trying to figure
out who we are,
especially when we're young,
it really calms your ego down because
you always know,
you know,
I'm going to choke some people out and
people are going to choke me out.
And it's just,
no matter what level you're at,
you also get it out of your system.
Like the one,
the big part of what men do,
they puff their chest up because they
weren't prove themselves and they
haven't yet and they don't know.
And so they want to like put up this
air,
like there's some bad mother fucker
because they're insecure,
they don't know.
And once you've done it a bunch of times
and you know,
trained for a few years,
it just,
it all comes down.
Yeah.
You notice all the,
all the guys who do it consistently or
the high level guys,
just Socom,
socom.
And that's actually one thing I noticed
about cameron too.
He's like,
he's a calm motherfucker because he's
spends a lot of time out in the
wilderness and I think that as a big,
uh,
you know,
with the world we live in now,
today.
Yeah,
we were.
Yeah.
And we talked about,
we talked about this,
some,
some of the experiences,
the stressful experiences and the hard,
I mean,
life here is never hard.
Really the challenges we face in the
regular everyday traffic dude,
sometimes the line at starbucks is huge.
I know that.
Okay,
that's hard.
Okay.
So aside from that tough cam with a k,
right,
but so I mean it puts it in perspective,
it's just Kinda like what you're saying.
But yeah,
you need to experiences like that.
Just you kind of simulate those in
training or,
and you know,
the hunts that I do or the races that I
do and it keeps it in perspective so you
don't get wound up over the little
stuff.
It's like no Biggie,
but it's also like there's a humbling
just being in the woods.
Yeah.
You just realize like,
oh this,
this doesn't matter if I never existed
now,
like if human beings would never
invented these woods would be exactly
like this.
Now that I've thought about that a lot,
I've been in the mountains and united
say if something happens,
if you know,
who knows,
you die for whatever reason,
nothing,
their changes and I oda,
I mean it's nothing.
So it's like your existence doesn't even
matter and I think we need to,
we feel too self important sometimes.
I think some people do.
And so in that situation and you're
like,
okay,
this I'm,
I'm,
you know,
nothing really.
My friend Ryan Callahan,
you know Ryan from firstlight?
Yeah.
He was out in the woods with a two
friend of his and they,
uh,
they,
they work for the park rangers or
something and they found a human skull
and they're like,
whoa.
And it just,
just puts it all in perspective,
like deep deep in the back country and
you find a human skull and it's just
like,
okay,
yeah,
this is real,
this was a person and something went
wrong and they just never really ever
found them.
And you know,
just happens to be a bear.
Could be a cat,
could be a tricky one.
Yeah.
I mean lightening happens a lot to
people.
Yeah.
But
I was,
I was uh,
I was telling you the other day,
Cameron about a,
I've been here a lot of reading about,
um,
about like circadian rhythms and in our
inner body because a,
I've had chronic,
a sleepwalking chronic night terrors,
uh,
since I was a little kid.
What does night terrors,
what's the difference in night terrors
and sleep parking?
Uh,
I dunno,
I mean I've had both.
So what is the night terrors?
Night terror would be,
you know,
sort of,
you wake up in the middle of night to
scream,
yelling,
well,
that's in the middle of the bedroom.
Um,
uh,
and they can sort of,
I think they can coincide with
sleepwalking probably,
you know,
so stress related.
I think so,
um,
it's hard to say I got him,
uh,
when I was young,
when I started getting them.
Uh,
I think when I was about in sixth grade,
um,
so I don't know if it was,
if it was a,
if a stress related or what it was,
um,
but I started getting them and then,
you know,
I've had,
I've had them in 31 now.
And so I've been reading a lot about
that and I obviously listened to your
podcast a lot about,
um,
just about the way humans are supposed
to operate in the natural life cycle.
Right?
And you know,
you,
you wake up in the morning because it
gets light and you go to bed because it
gets dark and we're screwing it all up
with the TVS and the phones and,
and all the stuff.
And anytime I've ever been willingness
to do a lot of backpacking and been a
lot of hunting trips and fishing and
stuff,
it's,
it really calms my body down a lot.
And uh,
what they said was in all the reading
I've done is,
is that um,
your,
your creation of Melatonin is in your
optics because of assimilation of light.
So when it gets dark,
you're,
your mind supposed to create more
Melatonin,
which obviously puts you to sleep.
But because we don't have that or we're,
we're manipulating that,
it's uh,
it's changed everything.
That's why they invented ambien.
Yeah,
works great.
I mean,
it's just a lot of people out there that
are taken pills that just knocked them
out just nor to deal with the fact that
we're constantly surrounded by lights
and staring at your phone before you go
to bed and watching TV and go to the
bathroom and the light's bright.
Your body doesn't know what that is.
And that's when we were talking about
this yesterday.
It's,
like I said,
I've never been born at peace and
relaxed and slept as well as I have in
the mountains.
You know,
once there's an adjustment period,
it seems like,
sure.
But once I'm there,
it's just like I've never been at a,
I don't want to make it sound like
anything bad at home,
but I've never been more.
Uh,
I don't.
I don't know if it's happy or just more
content content.
That's exactly right.
More content than I am in the mountains.
It feels like that's just natural.
That's how it's supposed to be.
Well,
people really are supposed to interface
with the wild,
with the wilderness the same way all
animals are.
We've just created these weird
structures over the past few thousand
years when you really think about
civilization that we only figured out
how to talk 40,000 years ago,
you know,
either we'll write.
That was,
you know,
I'm in.
Yeah,
I think the wheel is five.
10.
No.
Yeah,
it's a little little longer than that.
At somewhere around 6,000 years ago.
They figured out the wheel,
which is just hilarious with here's,
here's the best way to put that in
perspective.
Like,
so let's say it's 50 slash 500 years
ago.
That's essentially a person lives to be
100.
That's 55 people.
50th five people go.
They were just dragging shit around.
That's.
That's insane.
Yeah.
People go and then before that,
you know,
you just go back a few more people and
they were grunting.
Yeah.
I mean they,
they,
they hadn't even figured out how to
write things down.
They know it's really important
even,
you know,
what's,
what's even crazier to think about is
how we've taken airplanes and perfected
that in the last
50 years.
You know,
before that it was,
you know,
you didn't,
you couldn't just get on an airplane and
be anywhere in the world in 24 hours.
Oh yeah.
Totally.
Parents 19.
Oh three.
You want to hear the craziest fucking
statistics.
Emer.
Okay.
Between the time that plane was
invented,
the,
between the invention of the airplane
and someone dropping an atomic bomb out
of the airplane,
it was less than 50 years.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
What we do to each other.
It was like somewhere like 44 years or
something like that.
Between the invention of the airplane by
the Wright brothers.
The first flight and then a bomb
dropping on Hiroshima.
Yeah.
And then now they're fast and furious.
Eight bombs wise plug.
There is good.
You should go.
Just totally unrelated.
Just thought of that.
How many of those have you done?
No,
this is the first one that I've done.
This is the first one.
Yeah,
this is the eighth.
This will be the eighth one and they're
going to do 10.
Right.
So they're doing them back to back
because what they're doing,
I didn't.
That's the plan.
Uh,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not sure.
Vin,
vin diesel and the producers have,
you know,
the plan set.
But I mean that's the whispers.
I hear that we do a couple more.
I think we have tended to be cool.
We made it this far.
Might as well go to 10 right now.
Can you tell us,
does your character survive?
Can you give us a spoiler alert?
I saw the movie.
He said,
you can tell us then you're not
obviously if you didn't have to sign
anything.
Did you?
Was it was good last night.
I mean,
Scott had a big role.
It was,
it was cool because I didn't know,
you know,
you never know,
didn't,
didn't ask,
didn't anything.
But yeah,
he's all over it the whole time.
So it was cool.
He did a good job.
Let's just say it's a good one and
everyone will like it.
Or you also car guide.
Do you like muscle cross?
Yeah,
I'm a,
I'm a classic car guy.
I like classics.
I love the old sixties Ferrari between
Ferrari and for that whole rivalry back
then.
So the GTS.
Exactly,
exactly.
I'm actually getting a,
getting the opportunity to purchase a
one of the new GTS,
a coming out in 2017.
Really do that thing looks insane.
Insane.
And they're making only 100 this year.
Punch I hundred,
100.
One hundred and 7 billion people.
You're gonna make 100 cars as
collectibles.
Well what so,
so what?
I mean,
how much do they charge for those?
For 100 bucks or 100 of them or.
I mean,
I think the price is about three.
Three slash 50.
Three hundred $50,000 collected.
It's a beast.
Look at that thing.
That's the new one.
Sanity configurator,
you can fit why they let and you
configure it.
If you can't even fucking buy it.
Just bunch of teases forward.
What are you doing that doesn't even
look like a Ford?
I mean that looks.
That looks like a Ford on planet Mars.
Change in the code that lets you can
crap.
It was better than a Ferrari.
You know?
That sounds bad.
Ass Car.
Let me see the.
See if you got some other angles on it.
Is there any other angles?
We'll look at a pretty good.
Oh my God.
So cammo on reaper option.
Look at that.
Fucking God.
Oh my God.
What a beast.
I think I might get one to actually.
Wow,
go for it dude.
Go for it.
My whole life of a salary,
but that's $350,000.
But meanwhile the way they're making
cars today,
that thing is going to be insane.
But that'll be like a piece of art.
You know that that will be,
you know,
like the GTA,
knowing the older gts that have gone up
in value because they just don't,
you know,
it's hard to say that.
What about new cars though?
So much plastic and stuff.
They just don't seem to.
People don't want them.
You know,
like if you get a 19 sixties car,
it's worth a shitload of money today.
But in the 19 nineties,
current worth shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like there's no classics from
Nineteen Ninety is a couple Porsha's
like 99,
six floors from the nineties or the last
of the air cooled cars.
They're still worth some money there.
They're classics,
but that's kind of it.
Like maybe a few classic Ferrari's from
that day,
but like a Camaro from 1990.
Push that thing off a cliff and shoot at
it while it's on its way down.
Hey,
don't let your girl drive that car.
She got issues were saying before she
crashes things.
A little bit of a history of a long
history.
Let's leave it at that.
Listen,
people can't be great at everything,
you know?
That's true.
Have you seen the new Acura Nsx?
No.
Jesus Christ.
Look at this thing.
Jamie.
Pull that up.
If you're into cars,
you know,
accurate built the last Nsx in 2005.
So there's like 12 years off before the,
they came out with a new one,
they just came up with a new one this
year.
It's just this spaceship,
this monster,
a spaceships.
You'll find a silver one.
So I that when they do that with cars,
they sort of wait a long time to get,
you know,
come up with a whole new concept.
Not just a every three or four years.
Four wheel drive.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
No,
I like it to four wheel drive,
electric wheels on the front.
It's at.
It's tough looking at that one.
After the Ford is.
Well that's not a good angle.
Same Angle here with Ford,
but no,
love that for.
What are you talking about?
Get off the site,
the site bullshit.
They get you with the Kelley Blue Book.
That's it.
Click save.
You can see a three quarter view in the
upper left hand side right there.
Nope.
Yeah,
look at that too.
Dope car man.
When you see one in real life,
it looks like a spaceship.
It really does.
Yeah.
It looks cool.
This first today,
ma'am.
But that's like looking at,
uh,
the new hoyt,
then looking at the Ross,
Beau,
really you think that you don't think
that looks as good but not as good as a
four?
Does it pretty close?
I don't know,
Dude.
Everybody's got different tastes
campaigns.
I just can't wait for the self driving
because people just are terrible
drivers.
So let's just,
let's just get on with that.
We've figured that out.
Everyone's talking about these kinds of
cars.
Well that's fine.
Just let him be self taught or you know,
that's not going to be self driving.
They'll be ridiculous.
Imagine if you have a car like that,
like a Ford gt,
but it's self driving.
Unless you're on a race track,
you'd be like,
what am I going to live on a race track?
So stupid.
There's something that happening as
we're making things autonomous,
we're going to lose a little bit of
something.
Sure,
sure.
Sort of the one of the reasons why
people like handmade stuff now,
like you'd get a pair of handmade boots
or something like that.
It was like,
Ooh,
it feels different.
You know,
I got,
these are handmade.
Lou Casey's Casey's handmade.
They know me like 11 days to do,
to do from start to finish.
Well,
not the lettering and stuff they do.
I mean they do at different stages,
but I mean they're the best place in the
market and it doesn't that feel
different.
Like when you have them,
like there's something knowing that
person made it too.
Yep.
Well they're just so comfortable.
Yeah.
I made cowboy boots.
Cowboy boots normally aren't that
comfortable,
but those.
That's what my boots were yesterday too.
So Nice.
I was reading this podcast,
reading a podcast or listening to
podcasts,
listening to a book about a horseback
riding,
and this guy was explaining how people
try to wear like hiking boots when they
go horseback riding and they jam their
fruit.
He's like,
there's a reason why cowboy boots fall
off so easy.
It's so you don't get dragged behind a
frightened horse like it's supposed to
happen that way.
That's why they're pointed.
So they slide in and slide out.
They slide in and slide out and they
slip right off your feet.
Yeah.
Yep.
And you have,
you get a good pair of these.
I mean they'll last 10,
20 and it lasts a lifetime.
You know what I mean?
It could.
I just bought,
I got my,
the ones I had yesterday which were like
a thousand bucks and I just got them
resoled because I'd worn them so much.
Seventy,
70 4:50 brand new soles on.
I mean brand new boots.
I've heard that since you have your own
under armour sneaker,
that you're the Kanye west of bad
assets.
Is this true?
I don't know what that means.
None of the Kanye west of bowhunting.
Oh,
well,
because Kanye West has yeezys.
Do you know what Yeezys on his shoe?
Jamie buys them.
Look,
he's on yet.
He's such a Weirdo.
He's got like five pairs on this Weirdo.
So I don't even know what.
Hey,
see,
that's what the kids are.
Gaming aren't.
Those are a lot like expensive,
stupid,
expensive.
He can't get them when they come on
sale.
They are a lot like how much are they
reading the gate?
Uh,
the ones that are going to resale that
come out this month,
they're reselling for 2000 right now.
They're 200 retail,
200 retail and they sell for $2,000
because they make what,
100 pair like that.
Goddamn.
You can get a free one with the Ford Gt.
Yeah,
so I think so.
Anyway.
I think that's how Brendan's references
tied.
It's shoot Kanye shoe.
Yes.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
It's not that you're an egotistical
autistic rapper.
Not that I see him at.
He was at the UFC fight.
I don't know.
I was at college there.
Yeah.
I don't know which one it was,
but yeah,
that's right.
He was there with a boyfriend that j lo
dumped because he went to the UFC.
It was one of conner's fights.
Oh,
was it?
That's what it was.
Yeah.
The boyfriend wanted to go to the,
to the Mcgregor fight and Jayla was
like,
fuck that.
She's staying with me.
Jamie got a picture with them.
Kanye hearsay.
But here's Kanye West.
Even at the UFC fight just like this.
Well,
I saw him smile a few times when you met
some people.
Really?
Yeah,
but he's.
He needs a hug.
A smile.
Did Dee did you.
What'd you do?
He didn't smile.
Not your picture.
Did he pulled up?
What'd you do to get them to smile or to
go?
Well,
he's uh,
he needs a hug.
That's what I think needs a hug and some
good friends.
Something to calm them down.
I think so,
yeah.
Settled down.
Dude.
When we talk to you about your Prenup,
you got one right?
That's what I would say.
Areas that is not smile will smart.
No,
not really.
it's not.
You're just the smile from Tony
Hinchcliffe is bouncing off.
You didn't smile.
So he was like,
why am I fucking smile off?
This dude isn't smiling.
You didn't even happen to meet me.
Fuck why even taken a picture?
Hashtag blessed at least he's got to
clock on his,
on his shirt.
He's got 10 minutes in that regard.
That's the best thing about that.
Other than Jamie and Tony.
Yes,
I agree.
The Tupac shirts.
Good move.
If you're,
you know,
I don't know.
The rapper world is a very fucking
strange world.
I can't even imagine.
I can't even imagine now.
But Hey,
I did want to ask something.
So when you were growing up,
was there a pressure because your dad
was Clint Eastwood,
did you get,
and then you said you wanted to be an
actor,
you knew was that,
was that we're going back to it,
but I just want.
It's good.
Good question.
Well,
I think,
I think I always wanted to be a tell
stores.
I don't know if I necessarily knew I
wanted to be an actor.
I think as I get older I realize it's
more about telling stories.
Um,
I just sort of fell into the acting.
I was like,
okay,
well this could be a way I could get in.
I could,
I could go into that.
You just enjoy the entertainment
process,
like creating something that people are
entertained by and enjoy.
Yeah,
exactly.
Telling a story that people can relate
to,
laugh,
cry,
whatever.
Do you think you'll go the route of your
dad and maybe do some directing and
writing things on the plan.
That's the plan.
You know,
taking control of your own career,
uh,
is,
is good.
And it's also,
you know,
you tell the stories you want to tell
and we were talking about this before
the podcast that the world of the actor,
it's very difficult and a lot of people
like accused actors of being fake.
And I think one of the reasons for
narcissistic,
yeah,
that for sure,
but one of the reasons for the accusing
them of being fake is that they always
have to put on
the best show,
like as far as their behavior and the
way they act and think and their
opinions because they're constantly
trying to get cast in things and it's
all about getting people to like you and
politicking.
And,
and we were talking also about like,
you kinda have to have liberal
sensibilities like in this town if you,
if you are a right going together,
does that even make sense?
It seems like they contradict each other
a liberal sensibilities as well.
The reason I moved,
uh,
moved out to La is,
you know,
years ago,
uh,
I just,
I got sick of either are great.
They're great people in La,
you know,
I'm,
I'm from California,
so I feel have a,
you know,
as a place in my heart here.
Um,
but I got to la because,
you know,
if you meet 100 people in La,
you might meet in [inaudible] 95 that
are full of Shit and you know,
five good ones.
Uh,
and,
and that
generous that.
Yeah,
it's a problem.
Right?
And everyone's always.
I always judge it when,
when I meet somebody and I'm having a
conversation with them and I asked how
they're doing,
you know,
meet an actor or something.
How have you been working on a cool.
And you know,
a lot of times they're just waiting for
their turn to talk.
You're not even listening to you,
you're just sort of,
you know,
did you,
they're not going to return that and say
hello,
what are you doing?
What you know,
what's going on?
Yeah.
You don't feel like it's sincere
conversation?
No,
not,
not at all.
Yeah.
That's a big issue with people in
general.
But in la it's,
I think this is the magnet for all the
narcissists and all the people that want
attention and the people that have a
whole,
they have a whole,
they need to fill up for whatever their
childhood,
whatever,
whatever the fuck it is.
And they,
they gravitate here and then they just
communicate with each other the same way
and everybody kinda like pretends to be
someone who they're not.
And then hopefully they make it and then
once they make it then they just become
some fucking Weirdo.
Just,
it's,
it's weird how many of them are like
almost like cookie cutter.
Like,
Oh,
I've met that guy before.
He just looked different.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's like the same person living a
different life.
I know this assembly line before they
fell asleep or something,
but the actor world is like,
I've met a lot of comedians that are
similar,
but there are a lot.
They're very so much.
But the actors,
boy,
there's a lot that are super similar.
Just a lot of you know.
But then again,
you'll meet some of them who've like
figured it out and made it through and
they're super normal and real.
Like Adam Sandler is one of the nicest
guys you've ever met.
Your lovely.
Oh my God.
He couldn't be nicer.
Totally.
Like if you didn't know he was Adam
Sandler and you met him,
you'd be like,
ah,
someone's dad.
Fucking super normal dude.
Yeah.
Tom Hanks,
you said super normal.
That's what people say,
you know,
like,
because they asked me,
Oh,
how's Scott?
You know,
seems normal.
So that's why.
That's why.
So you must not know me yet because it
actor is like,
I don't know who am I to say who's
normal?
Right.
But to me it seems like a normal guy.
And you said Adam Sandler over
completely normal.
So that's Kinda puts it in perspective.
My normal is like the,
you could talk to them and they're
really,
they're,
they're real sincere.
The president president having a real
conversation with you and there's a lot
of people that just don't do that.
You talked to them and they're just
putting on some.
He definitely no trust people who are
too nice.
I'm like,
why are they so nice like this?
This isn't right.
It's just a tough world for these people
anyway,
especially with the ones that haven't
made it out here.
It's so psychologically devastating
because you're constantly going on
auditions and you constantly getting
rejected so you're insecure in the first
place and then you are hoping someone
likes you so you'd go to this thing and
you're kind of like putting on your best
behavior and you're dressing good.
Like hi,
pleased to meet you a nice.
Alright.
Hey.
Hey,
thanks guys.
Thanks for the opportunity.
And we've like,
you know,
like they said you sucked at the
audition.
I didn't suck.
Yeah,
they just really didn't like you.
They said you didn't make eye contact.
Fuck man.
People get weirder and weirder.
And if you meet an actor,
say like,
uh,
like one year and then you meet them 10
years later and they're still swinging
and nothing's happening.
They might be like,
almost ready to crack.
Like right at that,
falling down with that Michael Douglas
when he's fucking and he's got the
briefcase and he goes and traffic starts
shooting people like that,
like a couple of days before the.
They're like,
take it anymore.
It's a fucking devastating business.
Right.
It's tough.
But you know,
like,
I mean we were talking about before,
it's,
it's all,
it's all built on hard work and your
reputation.
Yeah.
Because like you said,
you know,
and you can get a reputation for being
an asshole or,
or you know,
showing up late to work or this down the
other and you know,
everyone's gonna know about it.
So it's a small place.
La or being a diva in a diva.
That's a big one.
Right.
That's not a good.
That's not a good additive for.
Can't shake that one.
Yeah.
That happens to people.
Like in Hollywood,
they'll be doing a lot of big movies and
you hear like,
oh,
she's difficult to work with.
They just fucking disappear.
Sure.
And it's almost seems like Hollywood
delights and shutting those people out
there.
They're written for you to fail.
Yeah.
They kinda.
But one you prove to be like ungrateful
in some way or like here's a perfect
example where he kind of made it on
television,
but you remember David Caruso when David
Caruso was on Nyp de blue and what he
was like,
wow,
this guy's a great actor.
And then he quit and ypd blue and it was
this massive hit show and then went and
started doing like some real shitty
movies and everybody was like,
why the fuck would you quit a big show
like Nyp de blue and do a bunch of
movies.
Like boy,
I hope he fails.
And then the movies failed.
And then everybody's like,
Yay.
And then never did a movie again.
You never saw him in a good mood.
Like he like had this of this amazing
career.
Yeah.
Danny became this caricature because
then he was doing that stupid cop show
where we take his glasses off and say
some stupid pun.
Well it looks like he got nailed in your
tickets.
Remember that?
It was like CSI Miami or something like
that.
And it was a fucking caricature of a cop
show.
Whereas nyt PD blue when he was on it
was groundbreaking.
I mean,
it was fucking fantastic.
So what happened?
It just became an,
I don't know,
I don't know who he is being recognized
as a diva,
whether or not he was actually a diva.
I don't know the guy,
you'd have to meet him and talk to them
and hang out with them,
but he had that stink and you get that
steak on it.
That's the other thing too,
is it's not even,
you know,
in Hollywood is not even what's true
sometimes it's just perceived.
It's so,
it's [inaudible].
My Dad used to always say he say,
uh,
believe half of what you see and none of
what you're here.
And,
and that always stuck with me because,
you know,
you sit down with people in the industry
or whatever and you just hear,
know a lot of Hollywood gossip,
right?
It's a full of gossip queens.
Everybody wants to talk shit about
someone they worked with or tell some
story,
tell how difficult somebody was or this,
that.
And you don't even,
you know,
it's a business built on,
it's a,
it's just a house of cards,
you know,
you're like,
well that how didn't even know that
that's even true,
you know,
so it's Kinda fucked up.
It's,
you know,
I mean,
I don't feel like that happens in other
businesses,
but may,
May.
Maybe it does with coworkers.
I don't know.
I don't.
Maybe it does.
It's also,
there's a weird thing because when
you're a movie star like yourself in,
you're on the screen,
like you get all the adulation and all
the love.
There's a whole crew of people behind
you.
This special effects people and lighting
and sound and its directors and Jamie,
Jamie,
Jamie is 100 people to everyone that's
on the screen.
Right?
And so,
and they get no love,
right?
They get no,
they're going to 11.
And that's where the business side of
the businesses.
So delusion because the agents and the
people around us,
they're not the ones they're putting in
the sweat every day for five months to
make a film,
you know,
pulling the creative ideas,
pulling the hard work.
You know,
the,
the grips and all the,
all the guys who are underpaid in or you
know,
working just to make money to feed their
families.
Uh,
so it's,
it's interesting because I saw it from a
very different Lens.
I saw it from my father's Lens,
which is,
you know,
my,
my dad show up on time,
get the movie done,
shoot a fast,
treat everybody good and you know,
work with the same people over and over
again.
You'll do the right thing by people have
integrity,
whereas people don't see that side of,
of,
of the business.
There's so much other stuff that you
never.
The people never get love for.
And in the film industry.
Yeah.
Well the long hours.
That's another thing that people don't
understand.
If you're on a film set,
like what's an average day for you?
It could be a short days of 12 hour day.
So it's 12 to 16.
And how many days a week you work in?
Five.
Six.
I mean,
when you're on location,
you're usually,
you can be in a movie that's doing a six
day work week or you could be doing a
five day,
but by the end everyone's doing a six
sometimes even,
you know,
you're just putting in full.
You're full throttle to get the movie
done.
Now when you're on location,
do you have to squeeze a workout in to
keep your brain?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
How do you do that in a 16 hour day?
I try to do it during lunch because I
find that if you go to lunch,
you,
you get sluggish after lunch and then
you're going,
oh shit,
I got to get back in there and do this.
I gotta now.
I gotta hit the coffee.
I get hit the whatever to get
stimulated.
That's what you're saying.
Are you a math guy?
Or mostly just a bumpy get the history.
Um,
but yeah,
so I think working out during lunch it
seems to be the best thing for me
because I don't do well in the mornings
for workout because I feel stiff.
So I like to get the blood going first.
If I could hit it during lunch,
uh,
even if I'm on set I'll do whatever,
dumbbells,
this,
that,
and the other and then I'll have,
I'll get some endorphins kicking.
Yeah.
I used to,
I used to do that too.
But now lately over the last,
like not even lately,
but over the last like five or six years
I'd like to get up.
And the first thing I do work out,
especially like if I was doing Jujitsu
in the afternoon and I needed to do a
lifting session,
I want as much space between the lifting
and the Jujitsu is possible so I can
recover.
So for me it's like just get up and even
though I don't feel good in the morning,
once the blood starts pumping and the
sweat,
you got to just remind yourself like
does A.
Yeah,
I know you feel like shit.
Just do the few reps get that blood
going and then once,
once you're sweating you're sweating.
It's all the same,
you know?
Seems to be.
I do not do in the morning too.
And I worked out this morning and plus
math,
but I just that that helps me feel the
same.
So in the movie,
fast eight made a lot of sleeveless
shirts,
which I.
that's awesome.
You're a big fan of the other big fan.
That's why I slipped me a DM.
Stuff going on.
I'm sure about the connection.
He's confused right now.
I just know what we're talking about it.
But he'll press on.
So do those guys.
So rock,
state them,
mother to do we have to do pushups in
there to keep that pump for the,
for the scenes to.
Very good question.
Look everybody's.
I mean,
I think everybody wants to be on the,
on the,
you know,
at the tip of the spear.
Right?
And then you got shirt off,
tank off stuff.
So let's,
you know,
let's get the pump on.
That's where a guy like me,
I'm very,
very modest.
So if I was there,
I would be the opposite with your skin.
Tight muscle barriers.
I would try to slump maybe perhaps,
or hide my definition.
One of the first thing I noticed when I
walked out,
I said,
oh,
he's.
He really works on his posture.
I do do a lot of yoga.
I do a lot of yoga.
Very good posture.
You notice this cam,
you don't even notice,
Bro.
That wasn't even my friend.
Never commented on my posture.
That was.
That was one of one of the first things
when I.
I guess I got to yoga about 10 years ago
and it's changed my life.
It's amazing,
right?
It changed my life.
No pumping yoga.
There's no pump at yoga.
We've just got to Kim,
like sleeveless shirts and getting this
pump on.
It doesn't like touching his toes and so
that's a struggle I can do.
I can do this.
So knees bent.
Yeah,
but I think that's.
That was the one of the first thing a
guy told me when I was getting into it,
he said,
you really got to work on your posture.
He goes,
you're gonna.
You know,
look at,
look at guys who were,
you know,
90 walking around on the street who are
slumped over.
He goes,
do you want to be like that?
I mean it,
it Kinda got me quick.
I was like,
settle the fuck down.
I'm 31 years old.
How about you relaxed,
pow.
He's got such a better attitude because
I would've said worry about yourself,
but I'm used to getting critiqued on
line and so maybe I'm just a little
defensive.
Well these,
these seats that we're sitting in or
that he's,
these are these called Ergo depot,
uh,
is the name of the company and their,
it's called a cup pisco.
And what it is,
is they're comfortable but they make you
sort of sit and support yourself with
your spine.
Whereas a lot of times people just kind
of slump and chairs.
Sure.
It's just terrible for your spine.
Terrible.
Swamping is terrible.
All that stuff's terrible.
And when you order,
put in Rogan has order and save $10,
not a company sponsor.
Jose,
are you plugging every companies?
Coca Cola,
Pepsi,
if you,
if you do do yoga though,
like you will notice a difference in
your posture and the like,
the lack of like back aches and pains
and stuff like that.
Everything,
but it's just,
it's hard for people because it's not
necessarily fun,
like the results are excellent,
but why you're there and you're sweating
your dick off and you're stretching and
you got to quiet your mind.
That's.
I think that's the hardest thing for
people,
right?
Is,
is,
is that the meditation aspect of it is
so it's so hard for people to go to get
out of their own way,
but once you do it for awhile,
you realize you're like,
now I crave it.
I can't go.
I can't go a few days without.
I go,
I start getting antsy and I go,
I gotTa Kinda Yoga,
you know?
Yeah.
It's also a very pretentious thing.
Not really,
but it sounds like it is like,
I'm going to do yoga.
I'm better than you do yoga.
Then I'm going to have hummus,
you know,
like,
Oh,
I hate this guy.
Well,
you know what the thing was when I
started 10 years ago,
a buddy brought me in.
It was 98 percent female.
Now I've noticed it's a 50 slash 50.
You got to go to a different class.
Reason not to go.
What if there's a guy in front of you
and as you've both been Dover's of guy
sack,
like that's not what I'm trying to say
is I think that it was for,
for a long time it was state.
Yeah,
frowned upon,
right?
For men to go to yoga and I know I even
had those thoughts.
I was saying,
well,
you know,
Yoga,
I
want to go hit the gym and get,
you know,
get a pump on Jack,
get checked.
But now I'm going,
well,
you know,
you see all the benefits and everything
to incorporate that with,
uh,
with the pump.
For Jujitsu,
it's huge because range of motion is one
of the most important things that you
Jitsu and flexibility,
especially when you have a good guard.
And I got into yoga for the most part
because of Hickson,
Hickson,
gracie.
And I remember in 1994 I saw a video of
Hixon gracie doing yoga.
And I was like,
oh,
because I was like,
everybody would always say that Hickson
was like,
there was all these great gracie family
members.
Hands was great,
high end was great.
All these guys were great health,
but Hickson was always thought to be
number one and I was like,
well why?
Why is he so much better than everybody
else?
And then I realized,
oh,
he's got like the full package like he
has.
His Dad is Helio Gracie,
so his dad was like one of the
originators of Brazilian Jujitsu.
So he grew up with it.
It's in his DNA.
He trained his whole life under the best
teachers in the world.
And then yoga in training and exercise
like Hixon does balance beams,
which stands on a balance beam and does
a full split.
Standing up holds his foot over his
head.
I mean it's fucking freaky to watch.
He's just got incredible control of his
body.
So the dexterity and the control of the
body along with the strength and
Jujitsu.
Like that's what made Hickson who is,
you know,
I'm sure it's just,
it's again,
it's one of those things,
it's not as cool as telling someone you
dead lift 600 pounds,
you know,
either what are you doing to deadlift
and 600,
five,
six,
zero,
five three.
Yeah,
put chains on it.
Cause it's not hard enough,
that kind of stuff is going to,
that's going to catch up at the end,
at the end of your life,
you know,
that's,
that's tough.
You know,
it's,
if you're not careful,
you too much of that.
I feel like it's really going to cause a
lot of pain in your later life.
It can,
but man,
if you just do yoga,
you look like a,
like a month course.
No,
you've got to get jacked as well.
That's a little bit.
I don't know.
I mean depends on what you're trying to
do.
But I agree with you that it does give
you a calming thing.
Charms you down or away.
Yeah.
And I think there's Hixon look at that
picture of him on the beach,
you know,
I can't do that.
Oh,
he's unbelievably flexible.
You've got to get into it.
You got to do it.
Yeah.
I mean Hixon mean there's just not a
whole lot of human beings that I can do
that.
But forget about like world class black
belt.
Yeah.
He's a frequent combination.
Okay.
Wait,
so I got to go back to the fanboy stuff,
so I just want to ask.
So.
So you started off acting with like
smaller movies,
right?
Sure.
Then now you've been.
And tell me if I'm,
I know you were in fury.
Yeah,
I didn't remember until that's started
to know who you were.
This fury fury was with Brad Pitt.
Right?
Which one was a world war?
David Air.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
And then now feels like you've,
now
you're in the,
the big movies.
Well look,
I started 14,
15,
almost 15 years ago now doing it.
It's hysterical.
And people first SORTA got a couple of
movies happening overnight.
Success.
I know.
It's not always.
What the fuck you talking about?
I've been at it for 10 years,
you know,
at that point.
Um,
but yeah,
I started.
Yeah,
doing a tiny one liners,
you know,
any chance I got just to,
just to get onset a play.
Any,
any,
any role,
do any lines,
whatever.
Just learned,
soak it up.
And um,
yeah,
I was doing that for years.
I mean,
I was doing that for seven,
eight years,
you know,
Allah was bartending a while.
I was,
you know,
valet parking cars,
anything to,
you know,
pay the bills.
Right.
How important is that that you actually
worked your way through it even though
your Clint Eastwood son?
Right.
That's what I was interested in is that
it didn't feel like he helped use and I
don't know,
maybe he did,
but.
No,
no,
have you?
Anyone who knows,
my dad would just laugh at it.
They,
you know,
they're,
they would say,
oh yeah,
I mean my dad is very old school and
he's,
he's very,
very tough on his sons.
He has an older brother,
um,
and it's,
it just doesn't happen like that in our
family.
Uh,
there's no handouts and you want
something,
you got to go get it.
And I can't thank him enough for that
because it never gave me any,
a backup,
a,
it,
it didn't,
it didn't make me go well and I can just
sort of sit around or you know,
it created drive,
created,
you know,
hard work and driving.
Those are all the things that take to
make somebody successful yet like if you
were 22 and he made you a star of his
big movie,
that would been something that would've
looked.
It would've looked.
It looked really bad on him.
Yeah.
It was so and yeah.
I mean he could do that I guess when in
his movie,
but I think the common thing is,
well you had,
you know,
had it easy because you know,
somebody,
he can't just pick up a phone and call
some big director and tell him who he
should cast.
And if he did it would be a mess.
Yeah.
I mean for the director probably tell
him,
you know,
thank you clint.
But uh,
I keep not,
not doing that,
you know,
it was my movie and I don't even know
who your son is when he went,
when he went on TV and did that like
thing where he had a,
a s like a seat next to him and talked.
You talked to the empty chair.
We did.
You call them up and dad go,
what the fuck,
Dad,
what are you doing?
No,
I stay out of politics.
I don't even,
I don't,
I don't give two shits about politics.
I,
that wasn't even politics.
I was just like a play and he was like
a,
like a puppet show with no puppet.
Yeah,
I did like the intent though because I
hate,
well,
whatever.
Yeah,
it was good with it.
I get it.
But a straight Ho tongue and pen.
Hey,
didn't you try out or I'll let her know
how to but didn't audition this my wheel
wheelhouse.
But for American sniper I did.
And that was his,
that was his movie,
right?
That was.
So how'd go,
what happened?
Uh,
yeah,
I,
you know,
I auditioned and I remember actually
talking to I new Bradley Cooper and I
said,
hey,
you know what,
I love to play your Bra.
I'd read the script,
I read the script and you know,
I was already doing my own thing at this
point.
I was working for a long time,
but I go in periodically and audition
for his films.
Uh,
because there clint eastwood films get
an opportunity to audition.
Great.
And,
and you know,
when I said that I loved to play your
brother and interesting,
you know,
one of those roles and he proudly kind
of looked at me like,
eh,
I don't know,
maybe.
Okay,
cool.
Kind of brush it out with her.
I was friends with them.
And then,
so,
you know,
I sort of said,
hey,
can I get an audition to go edition for
this,
uh,
through my dad's company.
And so I went and put myself on tape.
Uh,
it's pretty simple when you go audition
for him.
He's not,
he's not there,
no one's there anything.
You just go put yourself on tape with a
casting director.
Okay.
And then,
uh,
you know,
either either hear something back or you
don't.
Yeah.
And that's sort of the,
that's the end of it.
And a lot of times you'll never do.
I mean,
that's,
that's how it goes for actors.
Yeah.
So that's what happened with that.
You,
you put it on tape and then didn't hear
back,
you know?
No.
You didn't say what dad would say.
Oh,
it didn't work like that in my family.
Really Nice.
He's too old school.
I would never even dare to bring up
something like that back to.
Yeah,
that's.
I mean,
that's probably why you're so normal.
Me.
Yeah.
Because those people that are in those
sheltered families where he's not good,
it's not good.
It's not good for you.
No it,
you know,
you don't have the value for a dollar.
The value for hard work,
you don't have.
Everything becomes
blurred.
Yeah.
I think that's the same way with
inheritance.
I mean it's very rare that someone
inherits a shitload of money early on in
life and then winds up having character
and being.
They say that Donald trump is like that,
that he's a cool guy.
Like everybody I know that's met him.
I know he gets a lot of weird press,
but the guys that I know that know him
say he's a really nice guy really down
to earth,
really normal,
really healthy and I've heard that.
I bought a lot of trump's kids,
which is really strange because he like,
he's this crazy,
you know,
I'm the best.
I do the best things,
my ratings of the best.
But you would think that he would be
like this Dickie Dad,
but apparently he's done a great job as
a dad,
which is very strange.
But that's what I hear about Donald
Trump Jr.
Yeah,
that's,
I've heard that too.
And he so he does got to be cool.
She's got that goal.
MaYbe that's why he's cool.
I mean maybe that's probably it.
I mean it might have something to do
with it for real.
It just,
all those experiences in the wild.
Well,
no,
and we just today,
so we've shot a lot of.
I mean I've been doing this for 30
years.
You've been doing this for years now and
still it's so humbling.
Yeah,
there's,
you know,
It's not easy making a good shot.
Yeah.
Every now and then one goes right into
the neck of the target and you're like,
what the fuck?
I've been doing this all day one just
goes wrong.
You talk about ego checks.
I meAn anytime you think you're good at
archery for sure.
There's a,
there's a wake up call.
Yeah.
I mean it is not easy.
It's not an easy thing to do.
And then also it's like waiting,
waiting,
stocking,
stocking.
And then all of a sudden here comes a
time.
Ready,
get ready,
pull shot.
Now is it really happening?
Is it really?
And then you have to execute a great
shot under this insane.
The adrenaline is pumping and you have
you done bowhunting yet yet?
What have you bow hunted deer.
Have you been successful?
Have,
that's a nice thing,
huh?
Yeah.
Well what kind of blacktail?
What'd you went to?
California.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
and it'S,
it is like very.
It's very,
uh,
like you said,
it's totally in the pocket.
All of a sudden it's now an adrenaline
adrenaline and then you're,
you know,
it's over because either missed the shot
are you,
you know,
you,
you didn't take it.
And you're like,
you know what they say cam,
that there's a direct corelation between
lower heart rate and good archery that
there's actually been studies done,
you know,
like in,
in these european circles where their
target archers.
And one of the things that they've found
to improve.
Dudley was talking about this on his
podcast,
knock on,
on his podcast.
He was talking about that running in
particular is really good at lowering
your heart rate obviously,
but then also the side effect of that is
it iMproves archery and improves your
ability under pressure to keep your
heart rate down because your heart ways
naturally lower.
Right.
You know,
like your,
your resting heart rate's got to be
stupid law.
Like what is it?
I don't know.
Forties,
forties.
Wow.
yeah.
So I thought mine was good in the 55 or
something.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
You know what michael bisping's is 34.
Yeah,
she Is.
Yeah.
Nor most good marathon runners or low
forties,
you know,
upper thirties.
Yeah.
So when you have that going for you,
like say if your heart rate gets jacked
up and you calm it down,
you're probably still going to be like
within the sixties or seventies.
Whereas a guy who's like some fucking
baba with some big sloppy gut and you
know,
and he's taken rip fuel just so he can
get up to the top of the mountain when
he gets up there and see some of these
book,
he's tired,
he's winded.
His heart rates already jacked and it's
harder to execute a good shot and under
those conditions.
Yeah,
and I mean just like with running and
exercising,
you recover faster the better shape
you're in.
So yeah,
that's kind of why,
I mean it can go,
it can peak,
but then it's back low,
normal and then you're more composed.
So I mean it takes a while for those
guys to recover if they're not in shape.
After all my years of exercIsing have
just started running,
running.
We're running today.
We're running the trails today.
After this I'm going to keep.
I'm trying to keep up with him.
Ridiculous.
It's crazy for me buddy.
Doing jujitsu with hixon.
You know you're going to get killed.
Just go out there and do it.
Don't be a pussy.
How many miles are you going to do
today?
I'll probably 20 or 30 if he can make
that.
Just kidding.
You're kidding.
Scott.
Weird.
Choose honestly.
Sears.
Addy,
if you're training for the 230,
how many do you do a day?
Well,
you can do a marathon everyday,
right?
You'd kill yourself.
He was doing a half marathon every day.
At least
you know there's,
there's days or.
I mean there's weeks getting ready for
the big foot that I had ran 130 140
miles,
so that's almost 20 miles a day in the
big foot is 200.
five miles over.
Said.
What'd you do?
Seventy eight hours.
Seventy eight.
Fifty six.
Did you see that?
A ultra marathon guy who finished six
seconds passed the deadline.
Oh,
barcelona at the barkley marathon.
Yeah,
he fucked up.
I took a detour.
Now I know that that race,
they've been sending me messages and
they tagged.
I don't know if it was both of us,
but the other day on or did a tweet.
Somebody mentioned my name for it and so
the race actually tweeted and said that
I wouldn't be able to finish because I'd
be.
I'd want to get up in a tree stand and
kill some of the wild pigs running
around,
so it'd be.
Yeah,
I apparently I didn't know this,
but.
So that barkley marathon itself tweeted
that.
Is it Tennessee?
Oh yeah.
That's the place is infested apparently.
Yeah,
Tennessee.
So it's a.
And I got.
There's a whole story behind it.
I wish I knew it because I'm going to
sound stupid,
but there's a prison there and I can't
remember who was in the prison.
Some famous criminal killed somebody or
tried to kill somebody.
Anyway,
escaped and he made it a was out for 55
hours,
something like that.
Made it just eight miles in and they got
them.
So that's kind of how the race
originated.
There's a story behind it.
So the race is there around that prison
in that,
in that same country.
And so the goal of the time limit is
something around that 55 hours and you
have five loops.
You go one one way,
a first loop,
opposite,
and you have.
And the course isn't marked.
So you're navigating with a map that you
have to create yourself and to get the
checkpoints.
There's books there at every checkpoint
and you have a certain number of the
page and they say you go and pull out
page 12 of every book,
this is how it works.
And then you bring it back to make sure
they check you when you get the lap
completed inside.
Okay.
You,
he hit every checkpoint.
Here's all the pages of those books and
then you do another lap.
And what if you run with some douche bag
who's like,
fuck,
page three,
I'm pulling his page to page seven.
Could suck my ass.
Yeah.
Started pulling people's pages out.
I don't,
I,
you know,
there's,
there's honor in if somebody's working
that hard,
usually don't have to worry.
They respect other people working at
heart,
you know what I mean?
It's just kind of the thing.
Yeah,
the honor system,
they had the culture of it.
Yeah.
So I mean I wouldn't worry about
something like that,
but it sounds like a brutal race.
I think only me,
it might be up to 15 people now have
completed it in 25 years.
Whoa.
It's tough.
And this guy missed it by six seconds.
Yeah.
Jesus christ because he fucked up and
made a,
an error in his past.
Something happened and I can't,
I don't,
I didn't read the whole story.
But.
So you have to do it inside a 60 hours.
Is that what he doesn't like that?
Yeah.
And she was like 60 hours in six seconds
or something like that.
It says he,
uh,
when he was going around the race,
you've found that you came to a
staircase and there's no staircases in
the marathon.
So kneW doing fucked up then.
Oh boy.
He was a super sleep deprived.
You know,
he made a wrong turn.
You're two miles from the end of the
race.
Yeah.
Wow.
And there's no.
There's no course.
So you just run into the woods.
Yeah.
Jesus christ,
they have the map up there,
the topo map up there.
And you create your own map off of that
map and you can't use a map.
You can't use a phone,
you can't use a gps.
So there's navigating is part of the
same when you're doing it.
I want to do it.
I know you do.
You had to get entered is that,
that's a whole process in itself.
You have to sit and like a letter and a
dollar 47,
something like that into the race
director and they,
they select who they want in there and
then you have to bring a license plate
from your house,
from your home state and like a shirt to
the guy and then you're in.
Wow.
So it's,
there's,
I mean,
a lot of crazy.
I dunno,
it's kinda,
it's just bringing a mature.
Can you give them a keep hammering
shirt?
I don't have to be a specific training.
I think he chooses.
I dunno,
I,
I need to.
I watched a documentary but I don't
remember every detail.
Are you doing some really nutty one
soon?
Uh,
well I need to talk to,
to a candice about it,
the race director of the bigfoot she's
putting on,
um,
the moab a,
it's a to 234 mile race.
This will be the first one.
It's a low longest one.
There is.
So you're going to do what you did the
big foot 200,
which is 205 miles and then.
And then do another 29 miles.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
that's what I need to run a buyer.
I mean we,
it was successful last time.
We got a lot of people followed along,
whIch is what,
what we wanted,
you know,
because you were running.
Yeah.
I'm with the live tracking and It was
cool because that race is so special.
She's so special as far as her passion
for this and,
and I'm creating these opportunities for
people to really test themselves.
And she was on your podcast?
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of hers.
What's her last name?
Candice.
Burt.
And the key premarin number.
What would,
do you remember which number was a no or
five?
Was it?
I'm not sure people will find it.
Yeah.
No,
it was good though because she's super,
super cool.
And so she's putting on this new one in
moab and it's,
you know,
further than any other race.
And so I want to do it,
but there it is.
race number three.
Moab 200.
yep.
Why do they call them 222 to 34?
I don't know.
That's what I like.
The big foot thing called big foot two.
Oh five.
Goddammit.
Two hundred.
Five pounds.
Like I'd feel like thirtY four miles is
a little too far just to round down.
That's a weird number.
I mean,
I mean let's do the.
How about the moab 50?
That's closer.
If you're going to run on that.
I like that better.
Sounds better.
Just the 234 point three and p if you
run 234 miles an extra 16 probably just
like,
who cares?
I'm already dead.
It's a long way.
It was looking at that country.
Doesn't that look beautiful?
Does.
But it's going to be in july,
isn't it now?
Now october.
Oh okay.
So that's not bad.
You'll be fairly cool.
Now you were saying that when you do one
of these things,
you don't sleep like you slept maybe an
hour a couple of times.
Yeah.
And that's how,
you know if you want to win.
I'm the guy who won richard total beast.
I'm always asking how long because my
goal was to win,
you know,
I,
I didn't achieve my goal.
My goal was to.
I wanted to get the fastest ever.
So I came up short on that.
but what place did you place?
I finished eighth.
Yeah.
So I was winning through 62 miles I
think.
And richard passed me.
fuck richard.
He's a star.
But uh,
I was asking,
I'm like,
how long had he been sleeping,
you know,
at these checkpoints.
And they said 15 minutes.
I'm like,
what?
So I have like,
so I decided I wasn't going to sleep
until I got 100 miles down.
I wanted to get at least halfway done.
So it got to 100,
slept for about an hour and got up.
And then I ended up sleeping for three
hours total over the 78 hours.
So you sleep about an hour a day if you
want to.
If your hope is to compete,
to win or to a place highlight like I
wanted to.
You can't sleep.
You don't have any interest in doing
that?
No,
no,
no.
Yesterday I said absolutely no fucking
way.
Yeah,
we're kind of.
it's just,
you know,
it's just like,
it's a different type of test just to
see what you're capable of.
Yeah,
I get it.
I guess I'm just not that into running.
Do you run it all?
Uh,
like this morning I ran the treadmill
before I hit the weights,
but just a warm up because there was
nothing in the gym I was at,
but not really.
He can go with us later.
Yeah,
I'll come with you guys run.
It was run to conan.
Can we run to um,
a breathing break?
Dust or terrible shit.
All that crap.
I saY we run there and then shoot bows
there.
But this is what we really concentrating
on.
Isn't he like 10 foot tall?
He's a big tall guy.
Six seven are super nice guy.
Is he?
Yeah.
Very nice guy.
You went when somebody was on his show,
you went with them,
right?
Sturgill simpson.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I went and hang out with them down
there,
didn't he?
He won a grammy this year.
You won a grammy?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
He's a.
He's another guy that's like a super
famous super successful guy that you
would never know if you met him just as
normal as they get.
Yeah.
He fucking working on a railroad car.
Like he was working for a train company
just like a
couple of years before he made it.
His wife talked him into doing music.
She was like,
you know,
you don't suck at this.
Well,
that's what shocked me about when I met
cameron.
We were,
it came out in the conversation.
He's still working for a utility utility
companies that you're trying to get them
to quit for a year,
a professional hunter and,
and I was like,
you do all this great stuff.
I follow you.
What do you mean?
And he's like,
yeah,
I still have this other job.
And I'm like,
wow.
I was like super.
A lot of respectful.
I've been trying to get them to quit
forever.
We have more time.
I'm trying to get you to quit today,
that 10 today.
He's like,
let's go to Hawaii.
We can cut there.
They've got all sorts of access,
direct access.
It's going to be awesome.
So that's in june,
going in the.
I'm trYing to drag them along because I
to quit my job.
I'm like,
could we killed two birds with one
stone?
I know.
So it's likE,
yeah,
you're going to go with like shane
dorian or something?
Yeah,
shane's going to be down there.
My friend remy warren's going to be down
there.
John dudley is going to be down there.
She'd be a gale time spot.
I want to go for real too.
I'll see if we can make something
happen.
I'll find out what's going on.
But apparently a lanai in particular.
Well they say maui remy warren just got
back from maui.
So now we're on the south side.
Yeah,
they've got a lot down there.
So have you hunted there too?
No,
we never get a chance.
Have you hunted in south here?
Mostly in the southern California area.
But uh,
when you were hunting we still hunting
spot and stalk like,
whoa,
what are you doing?
No,
just stand and just knowing the areas
with,
with a,
you know,
a friend who knew the areas and walking
and you know,
a flushing them out and you were doing
it with that rostow by laughing.
It's not that he's just a little bit
self conscious about the roth man.
That thing.
That thing was a good.
Hey it killed a deer apparently.
Yeah.
So well now that you have a hoyt though.
Yeah,
that things like the most balance.
I mean you feel immediately there.
So there's new ones are so good.
It's so crazy because the first one cam
ever got me was only four years ago and
you think like wow,
that's,
you know,
that's pretty recent but it was awesome
at the time.
But if you had to go back to it today
and be like oh this piece of shit like
this,
but not really.
But both technology just keeps
increasing every year they get a little
better,
a little bit better.
Little bit better.
Yeah,
sure.
And you might not know.
I mean,
cause I always say it's like,
oh,
I don't,
I try not to be the guy who's like,
oh,
this is the best thing I've ever shot,
but it's slightly better and as we know
and hunting that,
that there's a fine line between success
and failure.
So that's slightly better.
Might be the difference,
you know,
a lot more an amateur and comparison and
I don't want to beat him.
I did it out,
shoot him.
He did yesterday.
He made a couple of times.
It's like you're taking the liberty to
remember.
Remember a.
That is the beautiful thing about
archery is that there really is no
perfection in archery.
I mean,
you can get a perfect shot,
but to be perfect every time you shoot
is never been done really well.
I will say by the end of the day we were
out there in the parking lot of a
riverside archery.
We had 46 yard shot and scott was laying
them in their nice tight group.
We were shooting three arrows at a time.
I mean so and that's just in a day with
that new blow that yet did.
Kim and I were talking about this today,
if people knew how good it feels to like
steady yourself,
anchor,
like look to that peep site,
breathe,
release that arrow and watch it or
something.
Yeah,
it's the best feeling.
It is.
So good.
Well we,
we filmed today and so I took a shot is
61 yards at that with my big old heavy
arrow and I shot and I was like run up
to the,
to the binoculars and I look and it was
a perfect shot and I was like so
excited.
He's like,
the first time I ever shot a bow and
that was not,
that's just how fun it is.
This is how excited I still get and
we're just in people.
I told joe,
I said,
if people knew this or I mean they're
going to watch this and go,
I want to do that.
That looks awesome.
If you're after 30 years,
you're getting this excited.
It's just up.
We were talking about this today and I
want to bring this up and I think
hoyt should do this.
The big entry barrier in in learning
archery is having someone teach you and
like going somewhere and not knowing how
to get started.
Like once you get started and you say,
oh,
I'm a 28 inch straw.
Oh I like a 450 green arrow and you know
all the stuff that you need.
Then it's,
it becomes easier to sort of do,
but the beginning,
it's so daunting and confusing.
The learning curve so long they should
have,
like hoyt should have a white academy or
a place you can go where you could buy a
bow.
They size you,
they fill you up to the correct draw
length and then you sign up for a class
and there's a teacher and they show you
how to do it.
If there was something like that.
Whereas like you know,
you can go take karate somewhere.
You could take jujitsu somewhere,
go try to take archery somewhere.
There's not a lot of places.
And if they are,
you know,
like the first place that I went to his.
Oh fucking sketchy.
No they weren't.
They didn't really know my draw length
is too long.
It's a good pro.
Shops are hard to find.
I,
I'm lucky with the bell rock back home.
Um,
and wayne does that.
Wayne takes,
takes the,
teaches them right.
He coaches them and it seemed like
riverside archery was that chris?
There Is a nice guy.
Oh totally.
And totally knows archery to so.
But those might be a unique examples
because there's a lot of pro shops.
I mean,
this guy who works with under armour is
telling me about his pro shot back home.
Um,
they like,
we're almost making fun of him.
His,
his actually not him,
but his cousin was in there trying to
get set up with a bow and it's just like
we made fun of him because,
you know,
oh,
he didn't know.
It was just like,
so you never know what you're going to
get.
You know,
there's all sorts of different types of
people out there.
I pulled up to the hotel to come up to
la to do some press and I open up the
tell of the hotel beller and I opened up
the door of my truck.
it had all the field trip come out like
the bellman is looking at me going,
what the fuck are you doing with
compound bows in the car?
In la?
Yeah.
They don't know how to handle that.
If you were in cams neighborhood,
they'd be like,
oh,
you bowhunting out here though.
I know chris.
Is this guy doing?
Yeah.
yeah.
It's going to kill somebody probably.
Right.
Or you're a big walking dead fan show
drives me crazy when those arrows just
sticking the zombie heads.
I'm like,
why do they just stick?
Carpooling is no pass throughs,
you know,
and that's a fighter.
And the kid Yesterday were,
they're asking about that.
They're like,
what would an air date?
Will you go halfway in like in the
movies?
And I'm like,
it wouldn't even.
You wouldn't even feel it slow down.
Yeah.
It would be like.
And I told them about the.
We put up this bear quip.
Joe,
before we,
I think before we realized the victim
that will come out of of bear hunting,
but joe retweeted the video of this bear
stood up and it was grabbing this beaver
up there and I shot it and we had a
gopro on the backside of it and the
arrow went through the bear,
came out the back side and it was just
like didn't even slow down now and just
kind of all this stuff kind of came out
with the arrow just like,
what was the sound?
That's the sound that arrow made through
the glass through the bear's body.
And then the bear went on a full sprInt.
Yeah.
Know,
like almost right where you guys work
slightly off to your right.
and when,
if you've never seen a bear sprint
before,
like when you see them lumber around you
go,
oh well I kind of get an idea without
thinking,
do bull shit.
You know,
that thing is like usain bolt when you
threw an arrow through it.
Right?
And that.
So that was a 400 pound bear.
So you could imagine what brian was
asking about.
What is he,
160 pounds?
that's about 110.
Maybe one.
Oh,
six.
Somewhere around there.
But anyway,
I told her,
I said,
yeah,
these bows wouldn't even slow down.
You wouldn't even know what I mean.
you would be too late.
It would go through you and then you'd
go,
what?
Just say,
oh,
why am I?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I see grandpa.
Yeah.
So walking dead,
grandpa grandpa's reaching out.
Man,
I missed that.
I missed that skateboard through the
clouds.
But yeah.
So with the,
with the walking dead.
Yeah.
There you got some rotten zombie head
and the arrows are just sticking in it.
Say,
hey,
speaking of near death experience,
I wanted to ask you this because I
listen to podcasts a lot and I talk
about dmt and you know,
some of the stuff you see when you know,
like it produces in your mind.
Are you producing in your body,
right?
Is that the chemical that you released?
Like when you die or when you have like
near death experience?
They believe so here's the,
here's the,
here's the deal.
They didn't know for sure until really
recently.
That was easy.
It was even produced by the pineal
gland.
Now that they know there's a guy named
is produced by a guy named rick
strassman,
dr rick strassman out of the university
of New Mexico and he put a put together
these clinical trials that were the
first ever fda approved clinical trials
on a psychedelic drug first ever on dmt
and they were done in New Mexico and he
did them and he wrote a book about it
called dmt,
the spirit molecule and one of the
things that he found.
It's a great book and one of the things
you found really fascinating,
and I read the book before I ever did
dmt.
The thing that he found really
fascinating was that these people had
used uniform experiences.
It wasn't like one person saw this thing
and then another person had a totally
different trip.
Now they all had like fairly uniform
experiences and here's the other thing
that's really fascinating.
Their experiences in manY ways mirror
the experiences of people that have been
abducted by aliens and people that have
near death experiences and the
connection they think is that the brain
produces this chemical called
dimethyltryptamine and we know that it's
produced by the liver and we know that
it's produced by the lungs and then in
eastern mysticism it was always thought
that the pineal gland was the seed of
the soul.
That It was the.
The,
the third eye.
Then in literally in reptiles as it as a
retina and cornea.
It actually,
it's like literally an eyeball in the
center of your head and in the vatican
there's a gigantic sculpture of a pine
cone in the vatican and that pine cone
is supposed to represent the pineal
gland so you can get a photo of that
gigantic pine cone.
And I was actually in the vatican last
summer and I had a conversation with a
guide.
We have this really cool guy who was a
professor who was explaining to us all
the different stuff that you know,
it's all the different symbolisms and
what they mean and they've eastern
mysticism and a lot of ancient religions
have always been focused,
heavily focused on the pine cone and
pineal gland and that is what that's
supposed to represent that,
that gigantic pine cone in the middle of
like people smoke pine cone or there's
some people.
Yeah,
there's some people smoke socks If you
give them to them,
but what I heard,
I heard that,
I mean over that now that there's some
sort of dmt is like plant.
It's plant based.
That is the thing is that the dmt
doesn't just exist in one plant exists
in thousands of different plants.
That's why they have iowasca when
iowasca is,
is an orally active dmt.
So dmt.
Normally when you eat it,
your body produces something in your
digestive digestive track called mano
aiming oxidate the blocks it,
right?
Yeah.
And so what iowasca is dmt from one
plant and an mao inhibitor for another
plant and combine it together and they
create an orally active dmt because
otherwise you'd just be tripping every
time you eat a salad like you,
you,
you get some wheat grass juice,
you chip your balls off,
but your body keeps that from happening.
But the purpose of that dmt and what it
does in human neurochemistry is not
really understood that well,
but what they do know now,
because of rick strassman and the work
of the cottonwood research foundation,
which is a foundation that's dedicated
to exploring these subjects.
They've found that in live rats,
rats or mice,
I forget which one,
that they've proven that their pineal
gland is producing dimethyltryptamine,
which is what they've always.
It's always been anecdotal evidence,
so now they know that it's not just
produced by the liver and the lungs,
but it's also produced by this little
gland and this little gland.
They think during near death experiences
and during heavy rem sleep,
it's producing dmt.
How much they don't really know because
they would have to get in there and
they'd have to somehow or another figure
out a way to measure it while you were
alive.
They haven't figured out how to do that
yet because it's in the center of your
head.
They'd have to drill and tap it and who
knows how the fuck they could do that
with today's technology,
but maybe someday in the future they'll
be able to figure that out.
No,
I mean I'm fascinated by it ever since
listening to you talk about it and then
watching your documentary on dmt,
the spirit molecule molecule,
and it was all based on strassman's
work.
Yeah.
So I mean it's,
it's crazy.
And then I tried it one time and it was,
it was,
it was unlike anything for the 10
minutes I've ever experienced in my
entire life.
Um,
and so it was,
you know,
after that I've obviously read all this
stuff.
Try to,
you know,
what's interesting is I think no one
will probably ever know until you do it
or no,
I just mean like there's something,
there's a phenomenon happening.
we as humans can't possibly understand,
will never understand in our lifetime.
Well,
you know,
there's two different ways of looking at
it.
Yeah.
One is that it's a human neurochemistry
and that there's a chemical that is just
producing these crazy visuals and it's
just all the meaning attached to is just
your own.
And then the other way of looking at it
is it's some sort of a chemical gateway
into the afterlife life and that what
you're seeing is like the souls of these
people that have lived before and all
the people that have ever lived like a
sea of souls and I don't know what,
who's right or who's wrong,
but it's impossible to describe like
describe it as just like you're just
throwing words around.
It doesn't.
It doesn't work,
you know,
and it's produced by your own body.
that's the weirdest thing.
Like everybody has it.
Like terence mckenna used to joke about
it.
He said everybody's holding.
It's a schedule one compound,
but everybody tests positive for it.
Like it's,
it's a,
it's illegal but illegal.
One hundred percent.
How do they,
how do they decide what it's going to be
illegal if it's,
you know,
if it's a plant based problem that is
the problem.
Just plants that all contain it are all
illegal.
They're all,
they are all legal and then it's
illegal,
but it's in all these legal plants,
but it's in thousands of plants.
That's part of the problem.
It's like you can have a san pedro
cactus and keep it in your house and
everybody's like,
what's that like?
Oh,
it's pretty cactus.
Yeah.
But it's also,
there's drugs in that fucking cactus.
I meAn that's where mescalin comes from.
Comes from that trip your balls off from
a fucking cactus.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I mean when the pod rituals,
that's from a cactus san pedro cactus is
this in the same thing as pay and so I
think,
see if you can google that.
Jamie pay.
I believe that pod and masculine or
slang or something.
Is it?
Yeah.
Masculine is occurs naturally in the
pod.
Cactus.
Yeah.
So you could have that cactus in your
house and you're basically a drug
dealer,
but meanwhile you're not.
You're a little old lady.
You enjoy succulents,
you know,
like go out of town for a week and come
back and it's fine.
Yeah.
So that's a really cool looking cactus
that people keep in their yard all the
time in la.
Like one of the things in la because of
the drought that we have for so many
years until this year,
which is awesome.
Everything looks like New Zealand out
there now.
It is nice,
but people would have these uh,
hardscapes in their yards where they
have just have rocks and succulents and
cactus.
So there's a lot of people that have
those cactuses,
that cactus.
You could go meet jesus with that
cactus.
Have you done it?
No.
No,
no dumb pot.
Yeah.
That seems a,
it seems like a pRetty cool long time
though,
right?
It's one of the longer ones I think.
I think it's a few hours,
but so as iowasca haven't done that
either.
I've only done the dmt.
Dmt is like a shorter,
more potent form of it,
but I've done it several times over the
course of an evening where it's like,
been like a couple hour experience.
Do you feel like it's obviously,
you know,
people who have done it,
they know it's just,
it's not something that you're doing
recreationally,
it's something that's like,
okay,
you do this this one time,
it's or,
or,
you know,
a couple of times.
It's not like you're out going to the
club.
Oh no.
You know what I mean?
It's a very spiritual sort of thing.
You do that word spiritual is so beaten
down.
It's oNe of those words that I don't
even like to use because it's,
you know what I mean?
It's like so many people,
like I'm not religious,
but I'm spiritual.
It almost seems like,
you know what I mean?
It seems like they get a spiritual
gangster shit.
I'm about to throw away as soon as I get
home.
Joe rogan says not cool.
Well,
it's not that.
It's not cool.
It's just,
it's kind of been cooptive by nonsense.
Sure.
You know,
and not even nonsense intentionally.
I mean,
people say that they,
like,
they'll say things and they don't mean
anything.
It's not that they're lying or they're
being deceptive.
It's just that it's such a problematic
word.
No.
Yeah.
What I,
what I mean,
I guess I can say better is,
is uh,
it's,
it's a experience that is something
that's very powerful.
It's very brief.
Yeah,
it's profound and,
and you,
you want to sort of do it and,
and talk about it and have a collective
sort of discussion about it.
And it's also,
there's also a real problem with
perception,
especially amongst people that haven't
experienced psychedelic drugs that when
you say the word drug or each day
psychedelic compounds,
maybe because when you say the word
drug,
people automatically have in their head,
oh,
you're a weak person.
You're trying to hide from reality.
You know that you're trying to shield
your sale.
You're just trying to get high and just
lay around.
I only want to be here,
man.
Couldn't be further from the truth.
It's like one of the most self
exploratory opening and deeply
disturbing and it's profound and
powerful effects.
It's very shocking and you leave it
once.
It's over you.
You're a different person,
man.
Now that you just,
now that you know that that's a real
possibility,
you're going to be a different person.
Yeah.
Maybe I was maybe won't,
I mean it mean it depends on where
you're coming into it and then what kind
of defense mechanisms you have,
what kind of an ego you have,
whether or not you can just realize like
now that you've seen this,
you know that life will never be the
same again.
You're always going to know that that's
a possibility that you can smoke this
crystal powder that is extracted from
plants and when you smoke it,
you're transported to a world of love
and understanding and geometric patterns
of infinite description to the point
where like you can't even describe.
You don't.
You don't even know what you're looking
at while you're looking at it.
It's just so beyond like lifts the veil
on what we think is reality.
Yeah,
and it might be heaven,
it might be the afterlife.
It really might be.
It might be.
There might be a reason why people think
that heaven is filled with ultimate love
because people have had near death
experiences and they've come back with
these stories and during those near
death experiences,
it's entirely possible not just
speculative,
not just like.
It might absolutely be that your brain
is producing this dimethyltryptamine
that had already produced in high doses
and that's what it's there for.
We don't know for sure,
but you've done it.
Yup.
Yeah.
A lot of people have done it now by more
people than ever.
It's crazy in history for sure.
For sure.
More people listening to this now have
experienced dmt than probably at any
time in human history
and it.
Yeah.
I tell people when they ask,
you know,
if you haven't done it,
you should do it because it's,
it's mind opening.
You know,
you go,
well,
okay.
You realize that you.
It's humbling.
I think to,
you know,
there's a lot we don't understand what's
happening and then we may never
understand and,
and to be so closed minded to think we
know one path or the other,
what's the right thing or the wrong
thing.
It's just really arrogant.
It's very ego shattering,
it's very ego shattering and it also,
once you know that that's possible,
that's like,
how is that possible?
How Is it possible that you're just 30
seconds away from that at any time?
And uh,
it was crazy.
Wow.
Yeah.
Can experience that.
No,
no,
I can't.
I get drug tested at work.
He drinks miller light though.
Why don't think it's even.
That wouldn't even come up on a drug is
a plant based.
Right?
I meAn,
that wouldn't come up in your test.
Positive for it always says you have it
in your system.
Okay,
let's do it.
Whereas back home,
just kidding.
We've got to go into a vault and michael
get mad at us.
Why he was mad that you're talking about
smoking pot all the time.
Really one couple of days ago for real.
What was he mad at that I don't know.
Silly.
Why would anybody mad at that?
Awesome.
Settle down,
mike.
He talks about drinking beer all the
time.
Mike's always drunk,
like they did this whole thing where
he's talking about being in vegas and
you know,
he was uh,
talking to gsp.
Gsp is like,
you know,
drunk.
He goes,
of course I'm drunk.
I'm in vegas because I just got here.
I was drinking last night.
He doesn't put up all the time that he's
drinking beer.
Did you see this jamie gsp,
gsp?
Uh,
no.
Bisbing about go.
You're talking about gsp?
No.
Bisping was drunk.
Okay.
And he and gsp called them out on it.
Like you said,
like you smelled like alcohol.
He's like,
yeah,
I was drinking all night.
The fuck's wrong with you.
I'm in vegas.
Well,
why would bisbing be upset that I talk
about beer?
Or I talk about pot when he's always
talking about beer.
That's silly.
Maybe that's not true.
What'd you sure.
Jamie,
you find that james is going to find it.
Hit his talking about you and just make
fun of me.
You and diaz.
Nick diaz.
That's probably trying to get a fight
with nick diaz.
That's probably what it is.
Maybe england for a fight.
I figured you would've seen it though.
I love michael.
I think he's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah,
that guy is tough as shit,
man.
Can't even see out of one eye.
I know.
Got one of the top fucked up.
They filled it.
They did an operation on it and then
filled it up with oil so that,
um,
it doesn't.
The retina doesn't rupture again when,
uh,
so he's fighting gsp.
When is that?
Do we know when they do not have a date
but trying to figure it out.
But bisping has said that if gsp can't
make it by july,
he'll find somebody else.
So he might fight michael bisping blast
joe rogan and nick diaz for positively
promoting cannabis told ya.
But that might not be real.
Like,
you know,
by saying blasts,
you'd have to hear like what he actually
said.
I can't tell what it's from.
It's all click bait nowadays.
She might've just seen that.
It might have literally an oh,
he's probably hanging out with joe
rogan.
See that?
Uh,
that 60 minutes on a.
I know there's words that you think fake
news or whatever.
You see the 60 minutes on it?
Hashtag.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
you know that word sort of popular now
because I think,
I don't know if some people have said it
in popular,
but it's,
it's uh,
it's amazing now.
All the people profiting on it.
It really showcases.
You should check out the 60 minutes.
Do you remember the,
you saved me from a bear attack.
There was,
there was a ha.
I got attacked by a bear.
Joe shot the bear and there's a whole
article that was all it was.
I got one that said I killed a mountain
line with my belt.
That's right.
I had a house in pasadena.
Yeah.
Do you do what,
what do you,
what do you think about that,
that you think that it's,
it's,
uh,
I mean all that stuff is pretty.
Do you think there should be controls
over it?
Like just outside of being,
you know,
the fcc,
being able to like sue people,
whatever.
That never really happens.
IT feels like.
Do you think that it should.
I don't know,
like things like the onion,
it's like when do you draw the line?
Because the onion,
it's hilarious,
so they'll make a like a subtle parody
of something and make it completely
preposterous and then pull up a good
example of an onion headline was like
the onion.
Do you don't know what the onion is?
The onion is a famous parody,
new site where they make stories that
just.
If you're smart,
you read it and you go what the bear
somebody who is making an parody on it.
Yeah,
yeah.
In a way.
Yeah.
And most of them are pretty humorous,
but occasionally people will tweet me
with like an onion store and like,
can you fucking believe this shit man,
it's good now to control.
And then you read it and go dummy,
this is a,
this is comedy writing.
People don't have common sense.
So that's a problem with that quickbase
stuff as they believe it because they
can't read it and be like,
ah,
that's probably whatever.
It's just like they believe everything.
Yeah.
But I mean isn't that the case with like
cults in the moonies and scientology and
like there's a lot of nonsense that
people believe in.
It's not hard to get people to believe
in shit.
Sure.
That's a good question.
Like what do we do about it?
Do you leave it up to common sense,
which isn't very common today,
or do you do step in rookie justice gore
such.
How do you say his name assigned to
supreme court.
Overnight shift a joke.
See,
because he's a new supreme court guy and
they're giving them the shitty gig.
See,
that's not real,
but if somebody read that,
they were like,
this is bullshit.
These fucking liberals.
They're just because she's a
conservative.
They're putting it on the night shift.
Night shift man tries using pink six
pound bowling ball to great amusement.
That's not really to see like.
It's like what they do.
They write these articles that are
comedy.
They fake their poses news,
which is a little.
I think it's different because right.
If you have.
If your fiction and you're posing as as
real news,
it's like,
where do you were?
You knoW,
obviously like there's no more
journalistic integrity.
It feels.
It feels like there are some.
It just feels like there's a,
you know,
it's just an ad.
You,
how do you know?
How did you know?
You read the news?
You're misinformed.
You don't read it,
you're misinformed.
You're not informed.
He was like,
well,
you know,
what do you do?
So have you been the topic of something?
Oh,
I mean,
yeah,
there's.
I mean,
there's been fake stuff about me.
Sure.
My setting,
my dad saying,
I believe half of what you see and then
what you hear,
you know,
I always laugh because probably some
silly thing.
My friends will come to me and say,
hey,
do you really know I didn't do that?
And there's a ton of fake stuff out
there.
THere's a ton of fixed.
I'm sure there's a ton stuff about you.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I just won recently by disarmed a guide,
the comedy store.
Some guy had a gun and I disarmed him.
My buddy of mine was a cop,
said,
hey man,
congratulations on the job.
Do like,
what?
Good job.
What did I do?
You save.
you save people's lives,
but you can ruin someone's life,
you know,
in a second,
in some way.
Say the wrong word,
some,
you know,
someone says he got throw is allegedly
or something.
Sure.
Allegedly raped somebody or something,
you know,
they ruined some poor guy's life.
Uh,
you know,
reputation just out the out the window.
Well,
that's what they've always been able to
do with those supermarket tabloids say,
allegedly from a source.
A source tells us that campaigns likes
to be careful here.
Exactly what I'm saying.
You don't have to do much more than that
and you kind of cover your ass and you
say,
I have to protect my sources of first
amendment.
Right.
And yes,
it's a weird time and it's a weird time
because essentially the boundaries to
publication have been dissolved.
It used to be that you had to work for
the New York times or the Washington
post or a newspaper,
whatever.
Now just all you need is a blog or a
facebook page and your breaking news,
you know,
and just scott eastwood admits to,
wearing women's clothes while you're
hunting for deer.
Larry,
larry,
david,
david.
I wear women's underwear.
One of the best line.
That was strange.
It is definitely,
you're right.
It's definitely strange,
but I mean,
but who's to decide?
I mean,
I know tHey're trying to work on some
ways to figure it out.
I know facebook is working on some
different ways to block fake news,
but who's to decide what's fake and
what's real and who's to decide where it
becomes parody.
When is it funny?
Like when is it the onion,
when it's pretty subtle and when is it
just some guy making up a story about
you?
Me saving you from a bear attack when
it's weird.
I know I'm ronald sweater.
Yeah.
No,
I'm really.
I'm really concerned.
Yeah,
y'all.
like asleep.
Okay.
But uh,
it's a weird sign of the times.
The times are weird.
We have weird times and this,
the ability to communicate where anybody
can do anything at any time and not
everybody could find out about it.
Like you could write something on your
twitter page,
just publish it and then it gets to the
right amount of people and then they
share it and then all of a sudden a
million people have seen it inside of an
hour.
And I know it's crazy,
but it's good to get,
I mean we've used that for our benefit.
That's what you do all the time.
But I do have a voice.
I mean it's,
this made you have a vo or me have a
voice,
you know,
you've always had one,
but make me have one.
And so it's,
it's an amazing time to.
Well even my voice is a way different
now like having a podcast and that's
much,
much in a lot of ways the same thing
because it's just,
I mean this is a pretty lean operation.
Obviously.
Just a surprise,
just a computer,
you know,
a jamie to figure it out and then we
talk and then upload it.
And that's it.
Yep.
Is that.
There's not a whole lot of steps and yet
this will probably get 5 million
downloads,
you know,
maybe even more.
So.
It's weird.
Yeah,
it's weird in that sense that it can
reach so many different people.
And then it's,
there's,
there's no corporation behind it,
there's no Washington post.
So we could just sit here and just make
up a bunch of fake shit and just be
really adamant that this really happened
and they were going to leave it.
And how could,
could someone stop you from doing that?
I don't know if theY could,
you know,
as long as you're not slandering anybody
and you're not getting sued.
So I did want.
So what's your prediction if,
uh,
if bisbing and gsp fight very
interesting fight because bisping's been
a,
uh,
a battler a warrior for a long time.
He's been very active and he's,
he's very,
he's a very likable,
Well honed machine right now.
Whereas gsps been out of the loop for a
solid three years.
No competition at all.
However,
he's been training the entire time.
So gsp is not a guy who sits around and
gets fat and it gets nothing done.
No,
he's constantly training.
But then again,
he stopped because he was having memory
issues and head injury.
Yeah.
I mean he got hit.
He had 800 plus times over the course of
his ufc career,
hendricks fight.
He got hit in the head about 10,000
times.
It seemed like he was a mess after that
fight.
It's just been a mess.
After a few fights,
know carlos condit had kicked him and
knocked him down.
I mean,
he's got some wars.
Matt serra knocked him out,
you know,
it's weird.
It feels like gsp.
He's been the champion,
but it doesn't feel like he's doesn't
have that champion respect for whatever
reason.
Well,
it's because his last fight with hendrix
was super close.
We've been controversial.
I did the fight companion.
No,
not to that fight.
I was there for that fight.
Hendrick's not hendrick's last fight.
I'm talking about gsps last fight.
Oh,
I was talking about [inaudible] being
no.
And,
and henderson fight that one.
Henderson,
that's when eddie bravo went full tower
seven and he got super drunk.
Was worried the illuminati it was going
to come and get us.
Um,
but.
And I said knockouts,
we're better than submissions I think.
Well a lot of people like it.
But gsps last fight with johny hendricks
who's super close,
super close fight and gsp retired with
the belt.
Yeah.
I thought,
I thought he lost that fight.
Just,
I mean a lot of people to a lot of
people did.
Yeah.
Either way.
It wasn't like this big victory.
It's not like the way he beat down bj
penn and stopped him and if he said then
I'm going to retire.
I had a great time.
Thank you very much.
Everybody would blood.
Yeah,
we love you george.
But instead it was a close fight and
people are like,
no man,
I don't know if he got the belt.
Maybe maybe show went out with a loss
there.
Who knows that,
but don't you think brisbane doesn't
have that championship type respect?
He does not right noW.
And the reason he does not because he
defended against henderson wasn't really
ranked that high and he really shouldn't
have got a title shot,
but it was a rematch,
one of the most epic knockouts ever
because henderson flatlined him and
punched him in the head while he was
down and flew through the air.
And that's henderson's logo.
Now henderson's logo is literally a
silhouette of his body flying through
the air,
ready to drop a punch down on bisping's
unconscious body.
Yeah.
So,
and then who else has the defendant then
defended it?
Um,
after he did that,
he,
um,
the faCt that,
you know,
he's fighting gsp,
that's the next fight.
So he defended it against henderson and
then the next title defense is going to
be against gsp.
He didn't have one before henderson.
No,
no,
no.
He won the title by beating luke
rockhold.
Luke.
Yeah.
He defended it against dan hendersOn.
I was going to fight gsp piece.
So the,
I,
the thought is how is this guy getting
to fights that aren't right,
luke?
You mean when you look at number one
contender rockhold yoel romero,
who's the number one contender who was
fucking terrifying.
He shoUld get the shot.
Yes.
Yo.
Well should get the shot.
Yes.
Yeah.
If you look at it in terms of who's the
most viable contender,
who's the guy that you would think would
be the most threatening guy?
Who's the guy that might be the
uncrowned champion?
You got to go with yoel romero.
It feels like ufc is.
Um,
I think they're trying to find their
way,
their footing a little bit with no.
Rhonda and conner.
No,
so they're just going after that big.
What can we sell a bunch of paper
reviews for gsps a big name.
What?
No,
no,
go.
Please go.
No,
I was just gonna ask to what's happening
with connor and that whole fight with
no,
it has not been worked out yet so it's
not definitive,
but it's so much money involved that
they think they're going to make it
happen
and that's.
And that's the ufc has got to come to an
agreement agreement or what did he get
in trouble with doc though?
Connor didn't convert for,
for I don't know,
not saying something and coming out and
saying something a while ago or get
fined or something.
He got fIned for the,
for the throwing the water bottle.
Monster energy thing.
Yeah.
They find them 150 grand and they
dropped it down.
I think they dropped it to like $35,000.
He said he'd never fight in vegas again
after that and so and they're like,
hey,
you rely on your because there's going
to go to New York.
It's debacle.
Did the big factors.
Another factor is also that the ufc was
purchased by wme,
that's an entertainment comedy,
entertainment companies going to try to
put on the biggest show they could put
on,
and that's not necessarily like the
number one ranked contender fighting for
the title.
I think that it's an entertainment.
I understand it's business,
I understand,
but it is also,
there's,
it's extremely important that you honor
the hierarchy of champion and top
challenge or I think that's critical
that you work your way up.
I mean,
you pay your dues,
you work your way up,
you.
It's ranked on ability.
Yeah.
So they're trying to manufacture big
fights instead of letting big fights
killed themselves.
Evolve.
Yeah.
Bill,
big fights evolve when you let a guy
like yoel romero fight and he wins a
beats.
Chris weidman by knockout,
and then if you fight michael bisping,
michael bisping,
michael bisping bto el ramiro,
michael bisping becomes a superstar,
you know,
and it's a tough fight.
It's a real tough.
If yo el ramiro beats michael bisping,
first of all,
he looks like a goddamn superhero.
so that's easy to sell.
You know,
you look at his highlight reel of
smashing people to the fucking moon.
He's a freak.
He's one of the greatest wrestlers it's
ever competed.
You know,
he,
he medaled in every single international
competition he entered.
He beat cael sanderson's when the
greatest wrestlers of all time.
He beat him twice.
He's just a freak of freaks.
Do you know yellow ramiro's to jamie?
Pull up a picture of yoel romero because
he doesn't even look real.
No,
he doesn't.
He's like,
one of those guys were like,
what is that?
That's a person.
Is that a real person or a cgi person?
Just so jacked.
Who did he?
Oh,
he beat a beat.
Everybody.
No,
no,
but in thAt last one with the flying
knee,
chris weidman.
oh my god.
flat lined them because it seems like
that whole fight,
he wasn't really doing much to get the
fuck out.
That's a real person.
But he did this fun.
This fight against,
uh,
chris weidman was sorta like hanging in
the balance and then he did some flying.
Hit him in the side of the head.
Where did that come from?
Pull up that video that you all ramiro
kaos my chris weidman.
Yeah.
There's an animated gif that.
oh,
here we go.
Go to the video.
It's fucking insane.
Like,
look,
even how he.
He fucking flies when he landed this.
Look how he turns around already.
Atlanta punches.
Here it goes.
Watch this.
Boom.
How recent was this fan?
A couple of months ago.
I was in Australia.
I don't think I saw down there.
He's just a freak and it cut the biggest
gash in the side of his head.
Yeah.
See if you get a clear video of it.
Superman fly from like another angle,
but he's just a.
Yeah,
a freak of nature and science.
That's,
that's,
that's cape.
He's capable of.
That was the second.
But like the amount of force behind that
is just flying through the air and
that's like so irregular to.
It's kinda like the way like chuck with
dell used to hit like real irregular,
like a flying knee to of well he's just
so.
He's so explosive.
So his ability to close the distance is
stunning.
Sometimes people aren't prepared for it
because he's such an athlete,
but in that fight it didn't feel like he
had been doing much.
You know what I mean?
I feel like he was just kinda like,
god,
what is he going to like get off?
It was a close fight for sure.
And then all of a sudden,
just out of nowhere.
Yeah.
So whether or not,
I mean if,
whether or not michael bisping can beat
him,
like who knows?
But he's got to give them a chance.
Oh,
I know he does.
He's going to give you all a chance.
Yeah.
So it seems,
I don't know.
It doesn't seem that life isn't fair.
Who cares?
but it doesn't seem fair that it's gsp.
Well,
the thing is,
is it a sport or is it entertainment?
I mean you just trying to put on a
spectacle or is it a sport?
It's a sport.
If you're going to have the world series
people play this guy to play that guy
and then it gets to the world series.
And here's the world series folks,
and this is,
we've had all this whole season we've
been building to this moment and this is
the hierarchy and it's still huge now if
it's just to show you the three of them
in there,
put your oil in there too.
With gsp and michael bisping.
I was saying all three.
I was saying that they should have
because you're dealing with a guy in gsp
has been out for a long time.
Yeah.
Having fight nick diaz,
he's been out for a long time to.
Neither one of them is ranked.
They'll both those guys before,
right?
Yeah.
I have a rematch.
That's the fight.
That would get a ton.
A ton of paper.
People would let people love diaz.
They love him.
I don't think people even know how much
people love them.
I don't even know if the ufc knows how
big of a star nick and nate are.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Sacramento,
California.
But bisping would like,
oh,
fucking smoking pot check.
Like fucking promoting use guys like do
crazy insane cardio.
Like bisping's kinda saying cardio.
The diaz brothers have cardio.
Yeah.
Nick has swam back from alcatraz five.
Whoa.
Five times.
I said twice once and he corrected me
online.
He said five now race ever.
They compete in triathlons all the time.
Yeah.
You know,
my,
you know,
my dad actually,
uh,
he was in a plane crash,
in his early twenties and it was off san
francisco and he to swim a couple miles
in that water will survive.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
He crashed into the water.
Yeah.
Most people don't know that it's,
it's,
it's pretty crazy heat.
And,
and I'm going to,
I'm going to butcher the details,
but uh,
just,
you know,
from growing up.
exactly.
Um,
but what happened
was he was in the army and uh,
it was right around the time the korean
war was starting and he was,
they were flying,
they were doing a routine flight or
something and they had to crash land in
the ocean and it was getting night.
And I believed,
I believed the pilot died and I could be
wrong on that.
The pilot died,
but his other guy he was with survived.
So him and him and this other guy,
they were swimming to shore and they got
split up because it was getting dark at
night and so then now they're swimming
alone and anyone who knows,
you know san francisco is.
Yeah,
definitely.
Jaws.
Water dumped him,
dum,
dum.
That's where they breed.
Yeah.
Early.
Great.
Whites breed in northern California.
There's like a nesting ground up there.
Yeah.
Fuck on now.
Or you want to crash a plane?
They're not where you want to swim from
five times either
in your underwear.
I know,
that's crazy.
I guess I've heard of that race,
but yeah,
that's crazy.
You've done that?
Yeah.
Wow.
So you're down at a swim two miles.
Yeah,
something like that.
It could have been more.
I mean fuck,
but it was a long for a couple hundred
yards.
Yes,
it means it.
I started looking for a log to hang
onto,
I think.
I think your dad has property in Oregon
or a house or something,
does he?
Not?
That I know of.
We've got a ranch up in northern
California,
is at a ranch for a long time.
I've been,
uh,
east of,
east of redding.
Oh,
okay.
It's in a vr.
No,
bernie is and that sort of area up
there.
And then like lake shasta sort area and
I think,
I think we have a big saw mill right
where I live.
Weyerhaeuser.
I think he,
this could be wrong.
I think he worked there.
Your dad worked at the warehouse or saw
mill?
Uh,
I don't know.
I mean,
look,
there's a lot of.
I've heard,
I've heard crazy thing I've heard
crazier.
Let's see if this is crazy.
Maybe as on dmt.
How often do you get to hang out with
them?
Uh,
well I've been busy a lot.
You know,
I was gone for six months in Australia
and China and then before that I was
working on fast and then before that it
was on a movie.
Uh,
not as much as I'd like,
but he is turning 87 this year and uh,
that's,
I'm taking some time off to really feel
like that's an important point in time
in my life to try to be around him.
Yeah.
Ed seven,
now that's old just happens all the
sudden.
You're 87.
That's almost 90.
I didn't know.
It doesn't feel like clint eastwood
would be almost 90.
Yeah,
I know.
I would've thought 70.
It's a strange.
Wow.
He's because he was told he had you when
he was like in his fifties damn son.
Yeah.
Just getting shit done.
No,
he's.
Well,
I got it.
I have a sister.
I have a sister who's 19.
She just turned 20 no next.
Wow.
He was getting it done even in their
sixties.
Yeah.
Slaying it.
Ooh,
I get it.
Yeah.
So he was married to that girl who was a
newscaster or something.
Right.
And then they did a reality show.
Well she did a reality show.
Yeah,
he wasn't,
he wasn't.
He didn't do it at all.
No.
He was in no episodes at all yet.
She might have gotten them into it.
I wasn't forced to episode.
Yeah,
I remember that was going on.
I was like,
huh,
this one,
I ain't going to work now.
That wasn't his.
It wasn't his thing.
Was he married to the.
Who was the woman in sondra locke?
Every which way.
But yeah,
never,
never married.
Oh,
they weren't.
Okay.
She sued the shit out of him though.
When he broke up with her,
there was like a crazy store that he was
like blocking her film projects.
She was trying to claim that and he was
like,
what a.
Yeah,
I don't think he has time to deal with
that.
Those kind of.
Well she had gotten some sort of a deal
when they broke up to do like some film
projects.
It was like part of like the,
you know,
separation deal.
And uh,
she was claiming that he was somehow or
another blocking them if I remember the
story correctly.
Well,
I've been like a woman's going to get
that.
He did.
He worked at the pulp mill.
Oh wow.
Boy.
But that's what you're reading this
wikipedia.
Yeah,
he did it.
Me be my.
I'll ask him.
I'll ask real bro.
It's on the internet.
It's got to be real.
I think he did.
Look,
I don't know if you know about
wikipedia,
but this is why I know it's real because
anyone can enter in information and edit
it.
Right.
That's crazy.
So it's so,
so 100 percent solid.
So solid.
Why would anybody put something that
wasn't true?
If I think wikipedia is still says Brian
Collins,
my brother really?
Who somebody might have changed it,
but I left it there for ever.
Yeah,
well he could.
He's as jacked as you.
He was almost dragged as me.
Clothes.
He was flexing close call flex light.
Crazy.
Silly goose.
That guy's the best to go hunting with
[inaudible] for five days.
Like we were like the last time we went
it was just nothing but jokes.
Just constant laughter.
He's because he's like,
he's the best at a captive audience.
Like if you're stuck in the car,
he's going to make us.
He's the guy that make make a scene.
oh,
well he's just funny man.
He's a.
He's like,
just,
I'm not funny that way the way he is.
He's like a,
just a natural showman wound.
Silly person.
Always silly.
And the first time I took him to Montana
we went hunting with rinella.
Like it was just,
it was six days of gut busting howling.
Laughter does.
Does.
Steve seems more like dry though.
It's funny.
Does.
He was funny guy too.
HE's got a couple of pops in them,
funny dude,
but collin had this character called the
ravine comer and he couldn't.
They wouldn't put it anywhere.
They wouldn't release the footage,
but they filmed it.
It was him who was doing this character
of a guy who finds every time he sees
ravine ravinia has to come,
so he runs towards it counts like
pulling his pants down and he's
screaming that he's shooting loads into
this ravine.
I mean,
I'm not doing it any justice because
he's like way over the top.
It's like,
oh fuck.
Like he would just,
whenever you'd see like sort of a valley
who would have to pretend he was jerking
off into it.
I'm telling you,
it seems so ridiculous,
but you know,
you're,
I think everybody's done that before
you're talking into a ravine.
Oh yeah,
of course.
But when you're little,
you know,
you get up at 5:30 in the morning,
it's dark out,
you're freezing.
He's the guy.
He's just mAking everybody laugh.
Yeah,
that's what he,
that's what he mentioned.
There was something weird about that,
like in the woods and you're waking up
super early or going surfing super
early,
you're sort of delirious and yeah,
and you're like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Why are we putting ourselves through
this shit?
and then you know,
you,
you obviously do your activity or
whatever it is and you're happy you did
it,
but it's a,
it's,
it's a weird delirium.
Our,
there's also some weird thoughts that go
through your mind when you're sleep
deprived that don't ordinarily go
through your mind.
So one of the reasons,
like some writers on purpose,
we'll wait until like really late at
night until they write.
Like the writers that wrote for news
radio,
those sitcoms to be on,
they would wait until like two or three
in the morning before they started
writing.
They would just stay up and get silly
and joke around those who simply
creative.
It can be someone that's usually when I
make a post that I wake up in the
morning anD read and be like,
oh,
why did I say that?
I did that the other day.
I was in New York.
I was sat at a bar and we were,
we were,
you know,
we were all celebrating sort of,
we were fast and furious stuff and uh,
I wake up in the morning and there's me
screaming,
you know,
singing tina turner at the top of my
lungs as long what's love got to do it.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
who is out of context.
It's a story.
It was so not part of any of the story,
you know,
it was just.
Yeah.
Drive in fast and furious.
Do you drive,
did you drive for real or did they.
I was at work.
We don't,
we don't,
we don't do a lot of the heavy lifting.
The heavy lifting is done by a
professional stunt guys.
It's a,
yeah,
it's a big liability first off,
you know,
and in those stents or I mean they do an
incredible job of keeping everything in
camera,
uh,
or at least a lot of it,
you know,
it's,
they can't do,
have cars flying over some marines and
camera and stuff,
but they do a really good job of,
of utilizing the stunt drivers talents
and keeping a lot of stuff.
You drive at all.
Is it ever you driving?
Yeah.
You have to like pull up to a thing
then,
you know,
do a couple of lines or seeing or
something.
But you're not doing,
you're not doing the
gone sideways around a corner.
Yeah.
You know what always drives me nuts with
those movies,
they crushed these awesome cars.
They take these awesome classic cars and
smash him like,
nah,
you know,
700 or something were destroyed and then
making this 700 cars.
What in the fuck man,
it's like the dukes of hazard,
like one of the biggest bummers about
the dukes of hazard is watching these
old chargers slam nose first into the
ground and then pretending that things.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There are some of that jumping out or
drive it off the snow mountain or
something.
Yeah,
there's some stuff still still cars,
but you know,
that's funny because you said 700 cars
were ruined.
I shot an iphone in slow motion one time
and people were saying how wasteful I
was.
I'm like,
have you ever seen a movie?
Do not kick.
That's wasteful of what gigabytes?
No,
I know.
So tHe phone I wasted.
Somebody could use that phone.
Don't you know,
you remember the first shot and I shot.
I was just shooting.
I shot with an arrow.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
an airfoil.
Wasted a phone shot.
Some here.
We shot some in that back studio for
unbox therapy.
Set up some iphones because they had,
they came out with some new glass that
was back when a 90 pound factor to blew
right through that thing that people
were like,
that's so wasteful.
You could given that to somebody just
like,
oh my opinion about every.
go watch a movie,
you know,
700 classic cars.
Yeah.
I mean,
I mean some are pintos or whatever,
you know.
I don't know what you'd call them.
Classic.
They might be old,
but the warning,
all the vin diesel driving car now.
Okay.
How about the shooting?
Did you guys actually shoot guns?
Because that's not out there somewhere.
You blank blank ammunition.
That's pretty standard on movies.
Okay.
Yeah.
Because you had some shooting scenes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I was told that when you do a scene with
a gun and blank ammunition,
you're still not supposed to point at
the actor,
you know.
No,
no.
I mean if anyone's got good gun
discipline,
you know,
I mean that's how I grew up is know
good,
done discipline,
you know,
muzzled down.
It's always.
I mean like even in a scene where you're
shooting.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You want to sort of offset it.
Especially if it's close.
I mean they do testing and stuff first
to see and they'll tell you,
hey,
you can't pass this line.
You know,
if you're walking up and you're gonna
pull a gun on somebody that,
you know,
we don't want you to go past this line
or so.
Um,
and then obviously,
you know,
hey,
can you not aim it directly their head,
they'll find like a good point for you
to aim and that that's with the camera a
little bit.
I had heard that that happened after
brendan league got killed and movie the
crow.
Yeah.
And that was a bad one.
It had real ammo in there,
right?
No,
there was like some of it.
Got it.
What happens is sometimes what happens
is sometimes you know,
and even in these airbags,
the same,
same sort of stuff,
they had all these recall on these
airbags is what happens is these blanks,
you know,
sometimes they'll,
they'll bunch up together over time if
it's an old blank that gunpowder.
So it,
it can harden.
Oh.
And then it can shoot like a projection
of a couple of shotgun pellets.
Wow.
And it just penetrated at that spot and
killed them crazy as a 44 magnum I
think.
So it was a ton of power behind it.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Good.
So now they just pointed to the side.
It would have like fight scenes.
Do you have to do fight scenes?
Like especially you have a martial arts
background,
she have you do scenes.
Yeah,
I didn't do the,
there wasn't a terrible amount of a
fight.
Slammed,
slammed against the wall.
I get slapped around a little bit in
this one,
but to assure,
you know,
in other films,
I love doing that stuff.
That's the fun stuff.
Especially,
you know,
because because you get to hang with
the,
you know,
some of the coolest guys on sets,
all the,
all the stunt guys,
you know,
they're all,
likeminded people,
all,
you know,
martial art background,
guys.
Um,
and so you're choreographing all day
working that out and then you get on set
and you're doing it or you're,
you're,
you're doing it with them because they
might be playing the,
you know,
villa number seven or something.
So then you're,
you've already sort of got a shorthand
with them and your,
that's,
that's the fun stuff.
That's cool.
It's way better than dealing with a
difficult actor or something.
Do you ever do that?
yeah,
it was the worst.
Oh,
come on.
You're not going to get something else.
Let's,
you know,
uh,
you'll,
you'll get me in trouble like sky's.
Oh,
that's right.
Oh yeah,
that's what I hear.
Yeah.
I thought it was torpedoes,
but that might just be lips and louis
slips yet in the scene.
Uh,
the rock picks him up and slams.
It,
holds them against the wall.
And was that real?
It's real.
It's real with some assistance.
There's some movie magic,
but he's,
he's a big guy.
I mean,
it's real.
You would have dropped him and choked
him out.
That dude is so jacked.
He took a photo of him after a workout
the other day and I'm like,
why?
He's huge.
So disciplined to 4:00 AM.
Does he,
is when you're on set with him,
was he just always doing that?
Like,
what's his deal?
He's just extremely disciplined guy.
Um,
you know,
I got a lot of respect for him.
He's uh,
he's,
he knows what he wants and he is going
to get it like he's not.
There is no,
no,
he is taken it down.
He's making movie after movie after
movie.
He's going to go do it.
He's a,
he eats religiously.
He's got to get these meals are,
you know,
which is,
I love doing a meal prep stuff because
it's great.
It makes his life.
One less thing to think about.
Right?
Um,
but he's very religious with it.
Fuck a dog that.
Look at that piece of meat.
He's more jack now than he's ever had
his life.
I think he's 44,
44,
46 or something.
Yeah,
just crazy.
Uber jacked.
Yeah.
He's continuing to get more and more.
Jack still still putting in the work.
He's not done getting jacked.
He's,
he's keeping pumping it.
He's keeping a gun.
It's just a.
When you see his schedule and his
workload and then there's always some
new projects doing on doing a tv show
and he's doing this.
Fuck.
Does he have time?
And he's hosting this award show and
he's like doing something for the troops
and then he's doing this.
Moving.
Finishing up.
That movement is like how I tell you the
travel is what kills me.
I know you probably,
you've been in show business for all
longer than all of us,
you know,
um,
and uh,
the travel is what kills you.
WRite these long flights and then jet
lag and then trying to,
you got to go hit the gym and I did a
podcast yesterday.
MY brain just wouldn't fire,
right.
It takes to me like a day or two who had
just flown in from buffalo and it just
takes a day or two like for your brain
to like rethink.
Like today I feel normal,
but yesterday I just was like foggy with
you.
I haven't tried it but I keep hearing
about the,
what you're supposed to do with the
light for the jet lag because like the
simulation of light wherever you're at
and then they have,
you know,
you're supposed to put on the eye thing.
Like when it's supposed to get dark,
like say you're flying into the light,
you're flying,
you know,
going away those covers and stimulate
wherever you want with whoever you're
supposed to end up.
And that really supposed to help with
jet lag.
I was reading a podcast about Alaska,
but people that hunt in Alaska and then
when you go up there in the summer and
you get two hours of a podcast,
did I say reading what the fuck is wrong
with me?
Why do I keep saying that?
That's the second time on this podcast.
I've never said it before.
Maybe I'm still not really recovered
from buffalo.
I'm in denial.
Excuse me.
I was listening to a podcast where they
were talking.
This guy was talking about how usually
sleeps like a baby,
but he went up to Alaska and because
it's it's only dark for two hours a
night in the summer where they were at
and I think they were in the brooks
range and he was saying that like after
like six or seven days started getting
delusional and just delirious.
You know what's going on?
That circadian rhythm,
is that just the Light?
Because say the light affects the optic
nerves where you're supposed to produce
melatonin.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and this guy was saying that the way to
mitigate that,
that he didn't know at the time,
but he was told by someone is to wear a
mask that those,
those sleeping mask you see in movies,
you always look so silly and movies,
but those things are actually effective.
Yeah,
I,
I been sloppy about it,
but a fucking Alaska though.
You need it.
I've been in the summer.
El.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
Right?
Many tImes.
Weird though.
We would have,
we would bear hunt until I used to go
with roy almost every year.
We'd bear hunt until.
Oh god,
I want to thank one in the morning.
It would go.
We'd go back,
eat,
and then go Fishing at like three in the
morning.
It was like dark for an hour.
Then we'd go fishing,
then we'd start baiting again.
Then we'd hung out that night.
Then we'd do the same thing.
No sleep.
Which part of Alaska we were.
It's like the who sit in a river,
so it's just north or south central
basically.
Okay.
It's just.
I've been up there a few times,
but until they see seward and then up
north where they do like salmon fishing,
it's whether the commercial guys will
come in and they'll,
they'll.
It's like the net them.
Yeah.
But they'll be.
The tides gets so loW stuff.
They'll,
they'll do like,
they'll drive on the beach of these
amphibious uh,
uh,
boats.
Yeah.
It's crazy and I'm like laid the net and
stuff.
It really is the last frontier up there
really is.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Too cold though,
too cold.
Dare you.
How dare you?
San diego.
I'm a total pussY when it comes to
whether you lived in Hawaii and now you
live in san diego.
It's like,
come on,
man,
you're in paradise both times.
You didn't get anywhere now.
Right?
It'S just one of those places where
people In san diego don't want you
telling people how good san diego is.
Like.
They're mad at me every.
There's a thousand thousand people
screaming right now going to fuck up.
The traffic's already sucks.
Yeah.
It's way worse now than it used to be in
san diego.
Used to be way easier to get around.
True,
it's good skydiving of use.
I have,
I have had dropped down the border like
alcohol and area.
Where was I?
There was some lake.
There's the olympic training center out
there.
Do you know where that is?
No,
I can't remember what the lake was,
but people don't realize about cindy.
Two is like,
it's a lot of ranch land.
You know what I mean?
It is obviously the coastal areas is a
little sliver.
And then uh,
you go east and you're right in rancho
santa fe in five minutes and it's just
beautiful.
Orange goes old California,
you know,
uh,
tons of ranch land people riding horses.
Goldberg's got a ranch out there.
Goldberg the wrestler.
Oh yeah.
He's got some bad ass place out there.
It keeps his muscle cars.
I thought mike goldberg.
No,
michael,
he lives in boys.
When we were watching ufc the other
night,
they were like,
bring goldberg back.
There was a,
uh,
there's a survey someone did online was
like,
keep jon anik,
me and dominick cruz was a.
And then goldberg was b and it was like
90 percent be.
Yeah.
I sent it to the ufc.
Did you know what do you look at this
when you think of that?
You know,
I get it.
People want change,
especially if they own it,
you know,
4 billion bucks for something.
But your signature on something,
I guess you want to change the color of
the car.
I bought a new car,
cost me $4,000,000,000.
I'm going to make it red.
I always wanted it red.
Or are you going to uh,
uh,
efficient ip and married them?
He going to commentate the.
A tough fight if you,
if,
if I mean,
will you be the front runner to be one
of the commentators that they do the
mcgregor mayweather fight?
Most likely no,
because it's a boxing match.
Most likely.
I'll just,
I'll be here watching it on the screen
for it though,
if it happens.
I mean,
I just don't think so.
I think it's that it's a.
I'm not a boxing commentator.
I know a lot about boxing,
followed boxing since I was a kid and
I've commentated on kickboxing baths
before,
but I've never commented on a boxing
fight before.
It would be kind of cool though.
They had a couple of two guys in boxing
world in you because maybe you were
there to collect.
They always have jim lampley.
Yeah,
right.
Is that who they always have in max
kellerman who I really love max.
I love that guy.
Yeah,
I would.
I would be happy To do a paper view with
max kellerman.
I think it'd be fun.
Yeah,
a big dude and a different perspective
just because with mcgregor coming out of
the ufc,
paulie malignaggi,
he's another one.
I really respect that guy a lot.
He's a great commentator and world
champion boxer that be maybe most likely
know.
Most likely.
I just do.
I'm doing less and less of those.
I just a.
I do 10 a year now.
I would use the most I've ever done.
I think it was up to like 24 a year.
It was just too much,
man.
You don't.
You're not doing them all now.
You're no international paper view
anymore.
You just said I'm own domestic.
No fox ones anymore.
Like all those big fox shows,
the cut all those out.
Oh,
I do now as domestic paper view.
That's it.
Gotcha.
So it's about 10,
10 a year.
Yeah,
the international magnetic.
That's just fuck.
We had fun.
We went to rio and watch the funnel.
Yeah.
Camp came with me down when she fought
betco hey,
a starch during the first round.
Thirty four.
Second time.
It was fun,
but you remember how sketchy it was and
we were.
We driving around a bulletproof car.
We got an armed guard with us
everywhere.
It's fucking.
I didn't,
I didn't have any of that.
They must,
you must be a pretty big down there.
Very important.
Yeah.
I thought it was for me because it could
have been.
They know a big.
Yeah.
And they know that you don't pack a
piece,
so they're like,
okay,
cool.
Yeah,
we was down there with gel and she was,
she was taking helicopters around.
Oh yeah.
To get around.
That was a,
that's the way to do it.
Yeah.
That was the way we were in sao paulo
actually avoid being carjacked.
Is that why she took it?
Well,
I think it was just.
I mean,
I imagine there's some,
maybe I have no idea,
but I think we just avoid traffic.
Yeah,
there's a lot of terrible.
I mean,
I don't know where we.
Where the traffic was.
Terrible.
There was one road.
Well that's real.
Yeah,
we're by the beach.
That was probably when we got to the
fight.
It took forever to get to the fight.
Like you have to leave three hours early
were like,
what?
Then you get in the car.
He like,
oh,
I get it.
That was wild was going out as well.
We're talking to dana lash on the phone
because it was right when cecil the bear
was happening.
That the line.
So the.
Oh,
excuse me.
I was reading about it on a tv show.
Cecil the kangaroo.
That thing was going down,
man.
Yeah,
I remember that as it goes at the time,
but yeah,
that was the last time I went to Brazil.
I was like,
I think I've been to Brazil five times.
I love it.
I love the brazilians.
I love the food down there.
It's fun.
It's great.
And everything like that.
We're going to go see chrYsler redeemer
that that was our goal to go do that.
Do You know what a process that is to go
see that thing?
No.
Really?
Oh My god.
it takes forever.
It was like a whole day.
You to take buses halfway than other
buses.
It's just like you cannot just go up
there.
Can't be just better to get in a
helicopter.
Pretty dope statue though.
Some may.
I want her to Be there.
So we got one from afar.
We add it in the background and we were
like,
it's pretty cool though.
it's pretty.
I'd like to fly it.
I'm,
I,
uh,
I'm a,
I'm a pilot.
I'm a real.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Yeah.
And so I'd like to,
I'd like to fly that.
That's kind of,
you know,
for pilots it's kind of like,
oh,
that's a bucket list place at.
Yeah.
Other places.
How does that work?
If you have a license in America and you
want to fly in Brazil,
obviously you can't fly a helicopter all
the way to Brazil.
No flY.
Like what's the longest distance?
Well,
it,
it really,
it really just depends on what
helicopter you're talking about and how
many people you're,
you're west.
So a lot of people's,
the furthest travel,
the helicopters ever gone.
Well that's a,
a black hawk I would imagine.
TheY have a dual engines and they have
their,
you know,
$11,000,000 or $20,000,000 helicopter,
whatever it is.
It's got,
you kNow,
a massive fuel tanks that,
you know,
a civilian helicopter can't go.
I,
so I wouldn't know the answer,
but I know jamie like a black blackout.
I'm going to guess.
Let's guess,
how far do you think?
I bet they can fly for 12 hours.
No way.
That's a long time.
I don't think so.
I think I'm hearing you say I'm going to
say 300 miles.
Yeah,
that's it.
I'm going to say that if someone's
chasing complete guests,
I have no idea.
I would,
I would kind of go on cameron syme.
I'm saying across the ocean three times,
so not even close.
If you're thinking 12 hours,
how fast do they go?
Well,
it depends.
If you're on a,
if you're in a piston helicopter,
you know,
or if you're in a turban helicopter,
like a black hawk.
Oh,
what's the difference?
Well,
piston helicopter is,
is like a piston engine,
you know,
like a car engine.
Yeah.
But it uses,
uses,
you know,
your,
uh,
your blades this in the same sort of
fashion,
but a fast speed on a,
on like a 44,
you know,
you like 130 knots I think as your v
one,
which is your miles without landing.
Two thousand 200.
And this is where we get your
information from a small helicopter.
that's an md.
500.
that's not it.
That's the black hawk.
That's not a,
that's not black rock concert right
there.
What do You mean it's not right?
It's on the wiki.
We already diScussed this.
Anyone can edit this.
Of course it's,
was wrongly was correct.
So,
so 400 miles on it or no?
Two hundred 50 miles per hour.
That lender goes,
that's pretty amazing.
And that's a,
that's a record that's find out what?
See if you can google a blackhawk google
black hawk helicopter.
What would you google?
Long,
long distance.
Long distance distance capability
capability or something?
Distance.
Let's see.
Two hundred 76 miles.
Wow.
That's a lot different.
Hey,
nautical miles,
300.
Three hundred nautical mile.
One hundred and 51 miles shorter than
other.
Similar rotated aircrafts.
Maximum altitude is 6,000 feet.
Tufts v 1:50.
Once they see they're pretty fast
because you know a turban.
Helicopter.
What you can get some civilian ones.
The md 500.
What does that entail?
When you say knots,
what does that mean?
Like mile per hour?
Wind.
Fifty one miles per hour.
I would have to check.
Why do they say nautical miles?
Two miles or longer than than.
I'm pretty close.
One point one we'll put one foot or one
five.
Okay.
So it's one point.
One mile per hour for every one mile an
hour.
Not to a mile.
So it's almost,
it's more than 100.
Fifty miles an hour.
300 or.
Wait?
Yeah,
I thought it was 207 instead of 150
knots,
didn't it?
A hundred 50 knots.
Yeah.
So it's one point.
One,
two each.
So 176.
What's that one?
51 nuts.
Top speed comes at 1:50.
One knots at 60.
One nautical mile distance.
Yeah.
I typed in distance and that's the so it
can fly.
Oh,
I see.
So would you.
Was this last one?
Knots or miles you just googled.
The second thing is just how would not
miles but not nautical miles per hour.
that's whether or not his medical mile
per hour.
Oh,
okay.
So the speed of knots is the same as
nautical miles.
Oh,
okay.
how interesting.
So I wonder why that was just.
She was miles.
Why fucking confused the shit out of
everybody?
That's a,
it's the same thing with the standard
metrics.
Did you know that?
Uh,
not in the nautical mile with the same
thing.
I just learned that I didn't know,
but it's just like adam putting up
celsius for temperature that the green
tree Australia.
I know,
I just say nobody knows what celsius is.
What we should.
He put up american dollars to just for
instagram.
What do you do with that stupid green
money?
Your money's the wrong color.
Sorry mate.
Yeah.
It's weird when you go down there too,
because everybody looks normal.
Then they start driving on the lefthand
side of the road and they talk weird
that the steering wheels on the wrong
side all fucked up.
They don't know what the deal.
They're not normal.
They are great people.
I was just down there for six months and
I really do like the australian people.
That's the second place I live other
than America.
One hundred percent.
Number one is Canada.
I moved to Canada first.
You would?
Yeah.
If shit went down to kill everything up
there.
Moose.
Look,
I think if it's the nicest people in the
world,
I think canadians are the nicest soccer
on earth.
They're always.
Sorry,
sorry.
Sorry.
What's it all about?
But so that's like the place I'd live
first other than America.
Number two is Australia.
It's a close second to especially
melbourne.
I fucking love melbourne.
Yeah.
such a great.
Like melbourne city.
I love both of them.
They're both awesome,
but melbourne and good.
I just had a great time in melbourne.
The amazing food this shows we did were
amazing.
It's just such a great time.
Yeah,
I really like sydney.
The,
the whole,
the whole country man.
It's just great and it's got so much
more open space and it's just huge.
It's huge for the amount of people that
have their less people than in the
greater los angeles area and the entire
country is the size of the United
States.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
That's awesome.
That's crazy.
It's a lot of country.
That was one of the reasons why the so
nice and I do hear though that there,
there's a lot of interesting stuff
happening in the desert out there with
nuclear waste that they're allowing them
to dump out there.
Oh,
they're trying to make some godzilla
type shit.
That's what I would do it.
See what happens is some spots out there
with nothing but spiders and crocodiles
throws me uranium out there.
There's some,
there's some stuff out there that can
kill you for sure that everything is
going.
He's had down there soon.
I'm super jealous.
He's going to do 18 days hunting water
buffaloes and kangaroos and shit.
You're going to shoot a kangaroo?
No,
it allowed to.
Are you allowed to hunt kangaroos?
Yeah.
Kangaroos.
Turkey.
Supposed to taste good.
It's supposed to taste like venison.
What?
Uh,
what movie were you doing there?
I was shooting a pacific rim.
Oh,
you did that.
How was that?
It was cool.
It was like the,
you know,
you're creating a godzilla monster type
things.
Right?
Right.
Like how do you act when it's like cgi?
What does that like?
I don't know.
I guess I don't know what it is.
What is it?
Pacific rims,
a monster movie.
Shit grows in the mountain.
The ground comes out.
Fucks everybody up.
It's like the dinosaurs.
But in the future of the dinosaurs came
back.
Wow.
Yeah.
Cool.
It's very cool concept.
Since guy you throw godzilla,
passive eyes rolled back and said,
it's like pitch.
I ran 200,
five miles.
I got no time for fucking monsters.
I'm a bow hunter.
I got no time for fake monster.
That bears.
That's what I told scott yesterday is
like,
you know a lot about a lot.
I said I know a sort of a lot about two
things running,
running in,
bowhunter it.
Anything else?
I don't know.
A lot and I know a lot about two things.
I know enough to pretend I know a lot
about everything else you asked you
about martial arts or comedy.
I can give you some long ass answer.
I know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Yeah,
but you get into other area.
I'm like,
hmm,
I better google jamie,
jamie to follow me around.
Zach,
do dobyns better jamie and pulling shit
up,
but you're in the middle of going,
wait a minute.
Is that right?
And then all sudden pops up.
Yeah.
That's invaluable resource.
That makes me look so much smarter than
I really am.
There's no way you can know everything
about everything and anybody who claims
to is an asshole.
This is just not possible.
Well,
how much information can you burn even
take,
right?
I mean,
good question.
You know they say some of them.
I've heard several times now that you're
only supposed,
you only supposed to be able to really
recognize 150 people or something like
that where you can have relationships.
One hundred 50 people.
Right?
Which is a lot of guys are super psyched
about that.
They're like,
yes,
this one thing,
1:50,
this is great.
Uh,
yeah.
It's called dunbar's number,
dunbar's number.
You keep 150 people in your head that we
have friendships with.
It's very strange.
Like the idea is that our brain was
designed to absorb the names and faces
of people that are in our tribe and then
when tribes get over 150 people there
essentially unmanageable.
Yeah,
I believe it.
I believe it too.
I think it goes back to what we're
talking about when we're saying that
people aren't designed for cities,
they're not designed for this life and
for televisions and lights that you just
switch on and off that were really
designed to say the reason why you feel
so content when you're in the mountains
and set your body's designed for that
literally.
Yeah.
And for hunting.
So yeah.
Sorry.
Anti hadn't psychos,
poor people.
I feel I hate the city.
Did you know the anti hunting people?
You know,
they just,
they get food easy.
It's easy to get food.
You should wasn't.
They would turn the brand.
They would fucking all listened to me.
You've all of you.
You would shoot a rabbit right in the
face if you were starving,
your kids were crying,
guaranteed.
If it gets ugly,
if it all gets ugly,
you become a predator.
Guaranteed.
Guaranteed because animals are going to
hunt you to fuck face.
Guess what?
You're out there in the woods by
yourself and you're making a lean to and
you have to fight the coyote that's
trying to drag your kid off in the
middle of the night.
Yeah.
That coyote gets roasted over an open
fire with a big smile on your face.
It happens.
Brendan put up a picture of the grizzly.
I killed up on his page yesterday.
Tom.
I've got a tsunami but her.
He had to take imaginable to text me and
telling me,
sorry about all the hate and I'm like.
I said,
dude,
I just told him,
hey,
you gotta take the good with the bad.
I said,
this is all part of the deal.
It's interesting to people,
you know,
they don't understand like here's my
favorite one ever when you were talking
about bear hunting and like you were
saying,
you know that the bear populations have
to be controlled and the woman on the
show was because you've killed off all
their predators.
Like What are you talking about?
Dinosaurs,
bitch,
what the hell is killing grizzly bear?
Are you crazy?
The only thing that kills grizzly bears
his other grizzly bears,
unless you want to have a grizzly bear,
cannibal apocalypse going on up there,
you've got to control their numbers.
Yeah,
I know,
and that's.
I told brendan that too.
I said,
listen,
these people just don't realize that if
the grizzlies,
the brown bears up there where you can
kill two a year because there's so many
of them that if we didn't control and
there'd be no moose deer,
there'd be no.
A lot of,
especially the moose,
they just focus on those moose when the
calves are dropping and so there was
follow up the pregnant female around and
eat the calf when it drops and with,
without us controlling them,
those it'd be gone 100 percent sort of
similar,
you know,
I don't know exactly the numbers or
anything aBout a great white sharks,
right?
Like everyone's protected those for so
long that then like that's,
that will start screwing up the cycle
because then you're the tuna.
So let me,
I'm gonna get this wrong,
but the tuna population,
because we're taking all the tuna
population,
everyone's so psycho over tuna and raw
fish,
right?
Yeah.
So then,
and we're protecting all the great white
sharks and some of the other sharks,
um,
we've just completely off balance the
situation because that's what they eat.
I'm sure.
Well,
anytime people intervene in the natural
world and step in and do one thing and
not the others,
we have to intervene sometimes.
I mean we have,
we get animals,
they just don't manage themselves.
What I mean by intervene is like what
they did in Australia where they brought
over a feral cats to control the rats
and rabbits and then they started eating
the ground nesting birds,
so they bring in fox is to try to kill
the cats and the foxes kill everything,
but the cats and ga's us.
Why did they bring the way?
It's a long story,
but they brought in rabbits in Australia
and the rabbit population got out of
control and then they brought in cats
deal with the rabbits,
but the cast didn't just eat the
rabbits.
They also started decimating the ground
nesting birds and all the other local
rodents and then they brought another
things to deal with the cats and now
hunters are like,
Australia is weird.
They're hunting magazines.
Water buffalo are not from there.
That's true too.
From asia.
Everything in Australia.
So the stags and crocodiles heard right
there.
Some of the big american crocodile.
we're not sure about that,
but I think they're from Australia.
I don't know about that.
Salt water crocs are huge and there's a
bigger american alligator and american
alligator over there.
They have alligators and Australia,
I believe there are no red and then I'm
not sure about that,
but I do know that they show cats in
their hunting magazines.
They're hunting magazines.
Dudes hold up catholic.
I got one might like,
and they think it's cool,
but it's the same as in America.
If you killed like a coyote that's
killing all the neighborhood pets,
people would shoot it with a bow and
arrow and then take a picture of it and
they'd be happy.
Yeah.
Good.
You got that fucking kitty cat,
eaton coyote.
But that's how these people are in
Australia with a cat.
It's all just culturally relative.
It's,
it's,
it's no different.
When we were there last time I was there
had this big,
a white stallion,
abrahm bs,
what they could sell.
Just a horse,
you know,
coming and uh,
adam's telling me,
he's like,
oh man,
that's,
that's a trophy.
You should,
you should kill that thing.
And I'm like,
why didn't kill a freaking horse dude?
And it's like,
but it's a brumby.
I mean,
so that's.
And it was by itself.
It was,
it looked awesome.
It comes all the way up.
I'm praying it would go somewhere else.
No,
it comes 20 yards.
I couldn't do it,
but that's just because you know,
where we grow up,
where we left the condition to,
to them horses too.
Then that's just,
you know,
that's something to hunt.
It's I ate at joe beef and montreal,
the restaurant.
It's a great restaurant.
Montreal and they serve horse.
They served a,
they had horse,
a horse loin and uh,
they also served horse tar tar.
So it was like raw horse and the horse
loin.
And we were like,
ooh,
it's an amazing restaurant.
But they're like super creative with the
dishes.
And both times I was there,
they gave us a horse.
No,
I can't do horse.
I like horses.
It was one of the biggest problems we
ever had on fear factor we made keep
lead.
Horse rectum can always.
Yes.
I remember that.
Oh my god.
Remember that show don't ripped a huge.
People were furious.
So sure it was.
That was the stop because it was for.
Because not because his rectum,
because this horse pig rectum was fine.
Not a peep out of people.
Nobody said a damn thing,
but horse rectum,
a huge issue.
Hey,
you want to cause more problems?
how about behr rectum?
You wouldn't want that?
No.
Baron?
Why is horse better?
I don't know.
Did that that showed you that show a
just fizzle out because you wanted.
You were done with it or was it.
No,
it fizzled out the first time because it
had just did a 148 episodes and it was
just enough,
was enough and they never really got
canceled.
We just kind of stopped doing it and
everybody was done.
Well,
I was just fucking stop and we walked
away from it and then several years
later it came back.
We did six episodes and it was canceled
because we made people drink.
Come.
What made them drink donkey?
Donkey come and donkey urine.
Nobody had a problem with the urine
oddly enough.
Really.
It's like relatively normal comparison
to the con,
but that was it.
Tmz got ahold of some of the photos,
some leaked photos with the donkey
episode and put it up there.
What did you call it?
Do not,
do not remember.
I think I seen sperm,
sperm or semen or whatever the fuck.
That's disgusting.
Um,
and that was the people that I was at
the studio of other people did it,
right.
Oh,
yay.
All three of them did it.
Yeah.
It was enough.
You gotta get outta here,
don't you?
You've got to go to conan.
Leaving soon.
Yeah.
Pretty sorry.
When does a,
let's get away from drinking.
Come.
This is troubling.
even to me.
I'm one of the very few people in
hollywood or anywhere in the world that
can say I lost a job because people had
a drink.
Come on tv.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
what's hilarious is that nbc said yes to
that.
They all signed off.
THat got passed through whatever
lawyers,
quality control.
A lot of people,
you know,
certain genders,
drink come all the time.
Both,
both genders.
That's unlike the people are either
switching it up.
The fate of the furious April 14th,
that's when it comes out this friday or
vin diesel and the rocket odds in this
photo,
I can't tell.
It seems like there was that piece that
I read or was that real and it's all,
it's all just don't believe,
don't believe on the internet.
Some real issues.
Those two,
then two alphas collided on the set and
vin diesel wouldn't take off the
sunglasses even at night.
It was so strange.
Yeah.
It's fucking dope cars though,
man did.
So um,
he took off his necklace.
A pay attention to that.
What kind of cars they have in this
episode.
Oh,
is that a charger with the flared
fenders?
Yeah.
You got like sort of seeped in charge
there in charge.
I got that sucker was on display
somewhere.
Right?
That charger isn't on display somewhere.
It might've been.
I mean it's,
it's one of the hero cars and fucking
insane car.
Like,
oh my god,
that's pretty sexy,
right?
That looks good.
Yeah.
Those,
those american cars from the late
sixties,
early seventies.
You just can't get anything like that
sexy.
God.
Amazing.
Yeah.
That one's got a custom grill to look at
that grill on that soccer.
Whoa.
No ram truck,
huh?
No camps.
A fan of the ram trucks.
I like try like cells.
Yeah,
I do too,
but they just don't.
There's something about,
you know,
you can't get a ram truck with a
supercharger popping out of the hood.
Like that big hole blower.
Look,
they're fighting.
Oh no,
that's jason statham.
Nevermind.
oh jason.
Say those fighting who rock something
that's out there.
That's the rock.
But brown.
Well,
pretend he's block.
He's got baby oil on and jason stayed.
I would help to pull them aside and go,
hey,
run.
Run.
Run the other way.
But he,
he fights.
He's got a martial arts background for
sure.
Yeah.
Jason statham can fight for sure,
but still run.
Hey,
look at that rocks.
We'll get that pastor jesus christ
features on that guy.
But young clint eastwood.
You handsome fellow?
I don't understand why so upset.
Angry.
I don't know.
The hollywood guys are angry.
I don't know why.
It's like,
so what's next for you?
Like what do you,
what do you got goIng on after this
schedule?
I'm not going to take some time off.
I'm going to.
I'm going to see my father.
Come on,
son.
I'm going to get a comment on if you
come to go to Hawaii,
he's going to go kill bears.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not going to do that.
Don't say that life.
Oh,
he's mad when I met.
He's not going to kill bears under any
circumstance.
We're just going to shoot over their
head and then take a picture of it.
So try to scare them off so I can't kill
them and let them know where the moose
babies are.
Right?
All those country little movements that
you love to eat.
Go get 'em.
Nice,
sweet,
friendly bear.
Can go eat those bare.
Those babies.
Babies you don't loose.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so yeah.
Would you not hunt bear because of the
blowback it look at hunting.
Anything I'll eat.
You know,
I never say never,
but I'm ict bear.
Yeah.
He can eat better.
Bear sausage is good man.
Telling you like black pair in
particular.
I get people say it doesn't taste good,
does it?
You eat it with the,
with the rivets.
We have some amazing bear meat dishes.
I mean,
jesus,
it's like you'd think it was the best
day ever.
The stir fry.
The means.
That was amazing.
Yeah.
Sausages.
I have a bare summer sausage.
That's amazing.
Bear regular sausage.
Italian sweet sausage.
Unfair.
It's fucking good man.
Yeah.
I bet.
And people just are not buying it.
Look at.
No,
no.
He's like,
I'm not shooting a bare bed.
That's wait until the publicist losing
her mind somewhere.
That's why we took her off air.
Yeah,
we're off air.
but is that why?
Because you would have anything to eat
and you wouldn't hunt that because you
wouldn't need it.
Well,
no,
I just,
I never had bear.
Maybe it's awesome.
Your bear sausage.
You can say shit.
I'll give you some real.
It really is good man.
And it's um,
the,
the thing is it's also an important tool
for conservation because they really do
need to keep those populations down.
Especially in alberta.
Yeah.
Tons of bear up there.
People think that like,
I go outside,
I don't see any bear bear populations
are so diminished because you're not
where they are.
If you go with the other goddamn
everywhere,
that's what I said.
I go,
yeah,
you're not going to see a grizzly at
starbucks,
but you know,
hey,
go up to Alaska,
you're going to see plenty,
and they managed.
Jamie played that video of that guy
that's sitting.
He's a photographer and he's a by a
river.
You take up and they pan out to the rest
of the river and you see like a dozen
grizzlies wandering through this river
jack and all these salmon.
Yeah.
First of all,
what the fuck you imagine you're sitting
there.
This thing just pulls up within 15 feet
of you.
You are only alive because it chooses
not to eat you because it's got a belly
full of salmon.
So this guy is sitting there.
This bear just,
he has to chase it off.
He has to yell at it.
It's feet away from him and easily a
thousand pounds.
It's an enormous bear,
right?
Yeah.
And if it had that right to kill you.
I mean it's not like you can look at a
bear and tell.
It's not like a dog with a wagging tail.
I mean,
you don't know that bear could think,
uh,
I just don't feel like killing you next
time.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'll kill you.
I mean there's,
there's no difference.
Our big bear family,
best buddies,
but people see this stuff and they
think,
you know,
barriers were friends with them.
got up there.
Who's the mayor?
Right.
And you can't find the guy.
Yeah.
Timothy treadwell.
Did you ever see that documentary?
The grizzly man losing anybody listening
to this who hasn't seen it?
This is what you do.
You smoke some of that devil's cabbage
and you sit in front of the old netflix
and he watched grizzly man because it is
a god damn unintentional comedy really
is.
It's an unintentional comedy.
So many comedic beats in that movie.
I was supposed to interview werner
herzog.
He was on a tour last summer and this
past didn't work out and we,
we'd never wound up doing the podcast
together,
but that was the first thing I was going
to ask him.
I was like,
come on.
Did you intentionally put comedic beats
into that movie?
Because there's one part where there was
a sheriff.
He goes,
I thought he was retarded,
that laughing.
He thought he was retarded,
but it gives me after the guy got eaten
by the bear because he was up there like
way past when you're supposed to be up
there too.
He was out there past friends.
They were friends.
There's one scene.
This is mrs chocolate.
Oh,
this is her poop.
It's right here.
This came out of her butt and he's like
picking it up.
He's like,
let's tell warm to warm because it was
inside of her and that's just a good
example of the bear might not kill you
just because they don't feel like it,
but when they feel like it,
it's over.
It's over.
I mean not a goddamn thing you going to
do about it.
Not a god damn thing.
They're a wild animal.
It's just like it's even the bears that
we had up in alberta.
I mean,
you don't know.
I mean they could decide they're wild
animals that any at any one.
There's all different kinds.
There's aggressive bears,
there's shy bears,
there's bears that you can't really get
a read on,
but it's just like a dog.
You don't know there's good and bad
bear,
so it's just the wrong one.
Yeah.
They're like,
all animals have different personalities
like cats,
dogs,
domestic animals have weird
personalities.
Wild animals do too.
It's just most of them can't kill you,
but bears can mean that 10.
Yes.
That's the difference.
Yeah.
So you're not interested in that.
What about eagleS?
Ever interested in cooking up an eagle?
Spit balls,
history,
eagle.
Nothing like a parrot.
Eagle balls,
balls.
I know that they're male and female,
but did they have testicles?
Look that up?
is this as important?
That's important.
Is there a bucket list hunt that you'd
like to go on?
Like maybe on an elk hunt and the rocky
mountains?
Yeah,
that'd be,
that'd be awesome.
I'd tag along and do one of those if I
can.
Yeah.
There's um.
well,
you know,
if you ever do get to Australia,
like they have stag over,
there are a lot lIke,
like elk and they roar.
Ever heard the roar?
Oh,
do they sound like a lion?
Have you?
You've heard it in real life?
No.
They look,
they roar.
It's crazy.
It's a crazy sound.
Jamie will find it for us.
We.
We've had some good outcomes,
so we have.
There's an elk back there.
I'll show you in the back that we got
just this past fall.
A huge thing.
oh my god.
That's so awesome.
Massive,
massive animal.
And I've got food back there.
If you want something once,
malcolm brick give you some tell you
right the hell yeah.
Because you had it backwards tonight,
right?
Yep.
Yeah.
After conan we gotta go do that.
Is that a stag night?
It's a rocky out on the elk bugling.
We've heard that before,
but go see a red stag roar.
Try google red.
There it is.
Yeah.
Listen to this thing.
It's crazy.
Look in his face.
First of all,
look at those goddamn antlers.
Yes,
he took.
That's high fan.
What?
What did that rocket?
A big old red lipstick.
Rocket.
Massive mended that.
Ladies,
you're so lucky.
Is he bringing it in?
Female.
They're really trying to.
He's trying to call him and see that
quarter to buy my homeboy turbo would
pound right through that shoulder.
Ooh.
We'd take that shot.
Would you take that shot and where would
you go?
Right through the shoulder point to the
spot right there.
Just right through it.
Yeah,
it would go right through it.
Cames shooting the most ridiculously
powerful setup we were practicing today
and it's just so evident that these
heavy arrows,
so much momentum.
You're at 687 grains.
Is that what that is?
Yep.
Which is by the way,
you know,
we were talking grams before and we
meant to say grains and then we're
converting grams to marijuana and
calculations.
Just don't mix.
We're doing this a long time ago on a
podcast and then I was driving home and
I was like,
jesus christ,
do we say grams when I met grains and
that we're trying to figure out how many
grams we're in an ounce and they were
determining that it was a pound,
like four,
500 grams in a pound.
And I'm like,
but arrows not a pound,
like whatever.
And we just kept talking on something
else and then it took me a while to like
figure it out.
It's like saying I was reading a
podcast,
but I'm.
His setup is just preposterous.
It's unbelievable horsepower today,
man.
Shooting good hitting that thing is
pretty cool.
Now you're ever.
None of them can be age.
It's not possible.
We'll talk later.
Has a trade secret engineer's.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I remember you told me.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
we'll talk later.
But yeah,
we have a.
Our buddy adam that we're talking about
before that liveS in Australia and when
cam goes over there,
you're goIng to be hunting stag,
stag,
buffalo and fallow and stags.
Just like an elk.
I mean it's essentially a real similar
animal.
Little smaller.
Yeah,
but it's.
I mean that is that arthur [inaudible]
buffalo though.
Buffalo is a video of him over there
hunting a water buffalo from 40 yards
and he's creeping up.
See if you find that video because I
read that book,
the last american buffalo renelle his
book.
You know,
I've read part of it.
I haven't finished it,
but I,
I started it and then I put it down.
I never went back to it.
As you get it,
it's sort of the first half is a little
funky.
It's clunky.
It's.
But the shitty writings.
I was just saying I'll call him right
now with kids since you're a cunt.
A shit about what I.
What I mean is it,
you know,
to talk about drinking just wouldn't
shut up.
He wouldn't shut up about that drink.
Some elk moved on it on.
He said something about vin diesel was
one time,
one time he doesn't like la.
I live in san diego and so this is camp
sneaking up on this water buffalo and
every time it picks up its eyes or it
might've caught movement,
he has to pause.
So this is ridiculously slow truck.
I think I'm.
I think it's still a little bit before I
shoot away.
No,
no,
no.
It's getting closer.
So I got my range finder there so I can
quickly get it because I'm getting
closer every time.
Kim,
what do you think about range finding by
nose stopped.
had a don't move.
Don't move with the hall.
If it's coming out.
You did you hide behind that little
tree?
What do you do?
I just wrestle it down.
Oh look,
a man.
Scrap wood.
It needs.
The hit you hAd on your podcast can take
down a wolf.
What was that guy?
Dan pena.
Pena.
Yeah.
He would just dab it in the dick over
and over again.
Sat right in the deck.
So he's a creeping up.
Kim,
what are you thoughts on range finding
binary.
Do you ever use those?
I don't have any.
Would you?
I mean like I know like there's some
companies that make some that bow
hunters use.
Like leica laika has one that apparently
has a button on the righthand side so
you can range and shoot with one hand.
This is adam.
I don't know what he was such that
shipment would be a trophy.
Here's,
here's some.
Here's a good illustration of having.
I dunno,
I dunno what I'm trying to promote here,
but a hard hitting arrow because if you
wash when I shoot this buffalo,
the arrow arcs up and actually hits the
branch and ricochets and still kills
that buffalo.
Wow.
Watch this.
It's going to hit a ricochet off.
That still killed us.
Big bastard.
Wow.
It's sort of deceptive here.
How many yards do you out?
It's going to be 40.
Yeah,
it looks like he's like 10 feet in front
of him.
Right?
You can,
you can because it's fucking huge.
Just skip ahead a little bit.
Yeah.
Skip ahead a little bit loud.
Okay.
Backup backup.
Because it looks like you already shot
at.
Yeah.
Backup.
Backup,
backup.
Scared.
Okay.
Watch this.
See that kind of touched it.
Almost barely grazed it.
Yeah.
But it affected the flight but still
went and pounded in here and uh,
that's right where you want to.
That's right into the heart.
That's where their heart is.
Do you think you would have got more
penetration but didn't graze that
branch?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
But still,
that's a 90 pound ball.
Yeah.
And it's going in six inches deep into
the heart.
Yeah,
probably more than that because those
are,
I mean that shoulders.
I mean it's,
it's in probably 18 inches.
and the thing is like what just
happened?
Now it doesn't know.
It just,
it runs into that thing.
And what's really crazy is that cam was
saying that he chewed a piece of meat
from that animal.
It was so tough and so strong.
You treat it for a whole half hour.
One piece.
Yeah.
As like shoe leather because that this
is an old bull to tank these things or
you know,
I don't know,
1800 pounds.
So you have to shoot,
you have to shoot heavy stuff.
So do you think you're going to be doing
that from now on?
You're going to be going to a heavier
arrow are in the range.
Maybe.
We'll see.
See how this week or this,
uh,
this trip works.
Yeah.
So how do we get you out,
scott?
What do we do?
How we get you out there?
Bowhunting with cam?
What's the animal?
I'll,
I'll go and cut for sure.
Is that a deer hunt with you and molly
or wherever?
Wherever you're going to Hawaii.
And I can.
Let's do it.
Get under armour on board.
We're all,
we're all wear the clothes and spring
smile at ea board.
Could you fire me today?
Maybe will just quit.
You got to quit your.
They don't know.
You probably hear I'm at work right and
at work right now.
He's punching out of your screen.
Was a couple of tweets to help help the
power business.
We should do that though,
right?
Yeah,
we should all do.
That will be fun for sure.
Alright,
well I'm fast and furious.
Eight.
It's at April 18th is the premier.
Is that is really fucking cool talking
to you,
man.
I really enjoyed it.
It was finally cam.
Always a pleasure.
Thank you.
And uh,
we're going to go run and I'm going to
cry.
So,
uh,
enjoy cone and you could Watch scott
tonight and we'll see you soon.
Bye.